i mean i've definitely experienced
moments where
i didn't want to do anything but chess i
also say that's pretty universal i think
if you want to be that the best at
anything you do or any sport you have to
be that level of obsessed
the following is a conversation with
alexander and andrea botez they're
sisters professional chess players
commentators educators entertainers and
streamers
their channel is called botezlive on
twitch and youtube i highly recommend
you check it out
a small side note about the currently
ongoing controversy in the chess world
where the 19 year old grandmaster hans
niemann beat magnus carlson at the
sinkfield cup
after this magnus for the first time
ever withdrew from the tournament
implying with a tweet that there may
have been cheating or at least something
shady going on
folks like the grandmaster hikaru
nakamura fanned the flames of cheating
accusations and the internet
made a bunch of proposals
on how the cheating could have been done
and it ranged from the ridiculous to the
hilarious
often both
hans himself came out and said that he
has cheated before when he was 12 and 16
on random online games to jack up his
rating
but
he said that he has never cheated in
person over the board
danny wrench from chess.com who i've
spoken with may make a statement in
response to hanza's claims soon
folks like grandmaster yakabuga spoke to
his experience training hans neiman and
has said that his memory and intuition
were quite brilliant
so as you see there's a lot of
perspectives on this chess base has a
good summary of the saga that i'll link
in the description
also note that this is so quickly moving
that new stuff might come out between me
recording this and publishing the
episode but i thought i'd mention this
anyway since the episode with the
beautiful sisters is a conversation
about chess and was recorded shortly
before the controversy so we didn't talk
about it
i'm considering having hans on this
podcast and also magnus back on the
podcast and maybe others like hikaru or
folks from
chess.com's anti-cheat staff to discuss
their really interesting cheating
detection algorithms
but
i may also just stay out of it
i find just to be a beautiful game
and the chess community full of
fascinating brilliant people and so i'll
keep having conversations like these
about chess it's fun
my goal with this podcast and in general
as a human being
is to increase the amount of love in the
world
sometimes that involves celebrating
brilliance and beauty in science in art
in chess
sometimes it involves empathetic
conversations with controversial figures
that seek to understand
not deride
sometimes it involves standing against
the internet lynch mob as the
chess-based article calls it to hear the
story of a human being who is under
attack
even if it means i get attacked in the
process as well
this is the lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's alexandra and andrea botez
you just got back from italy
what's the most memorable thing i was
just there recently as well it was very
chaotic because we went out on a whim
and we only had our first hotel book and
then we rented a car and drove around
all of the cities and went to like five
different cities in about a week and a
bit um so i think it was just the
variety of seeing so many different
places when we're used to being at home
all the time and andrea
is yours your luggage yeah i would say
it was the most stressful vacation we've
been in in our life and it was a
valuable learning lesson because now i
know how to be prepared for trips um but
we lost our bags and i never got him
back and like alex said we didn't know
where we'd be sleeping every night and
we're just driving through a new city um
with a giant van in the most narrowest
streets with and getting in many many
fights with italian men um so it wasn't
really a vacation i saw this motion so
many times
wasn't it liberating to lose your
baggage is it like a silver lining it
was liberating my entire life i've
always had the issue of over packing and
i told her for the trip andrea you're
gonna pack light right yeah alex yeah
and then i see her stuffing her over you
did the same we both had giant big extra
baggage that we didn't need and i'm
actually very glad we lost it because
for venice hauling that around on all
the boats and through the tiny streets
and there's no ubers
and now it's the first time where i can
travel without checking in a bag which
i've never done before so now i've
learned what it means to pack light
because i saw that i could survive off
of just my this sounds very dramatic but
it was really a big learning lesson for
me the driving must have been crazy
because driving in italy is rough the
driving was crazy i did most of it and
it would be really interesting driving
through places like florence or even
through uh the beach areas that were
super windy because they're two-way
streets that should really only be one
way so you'd be driving this huge van
and then another car comes on a cliff
and you're just waiting for it to slowly
pass so
it took all of my focus and
concentration to drive well in italy but
it was actually really relaxing because
the hardest thing about uh
making a lot of videos online is you're
always thinking about it what's coming
next and when we were in italy it was so
chaotic that i did not think about work
for a good week and a bit
oh cause you're just we were stressed i
was just trying to keep us alive
higher priority and that was kind of fun
it was kind of fun no planning nothing i
wouldn't recommend it or ever do that
again but
it sounds sounds pretty awesome and we
even randomly ran into two friends of
ours who were in the same city and we
just traveled with them for about half
of the trip yeah so you just took on the
chaos exactly it was an adventure okay
and i see like because you were using
your hands a lot you gotten you you
picked up some of the
the italian hand gestures i did we did
get yelled at by a lot of italians the
old italian grandmas would come to us
after breakfast because we'd leave
something on the plate and she'd be like
you could feed an entire village with
that tell your friends and we'd be we'd
feel so ash yeah we got cursed out a lot
but it really reminded me of where we
grew up and how true yeah bring back
those where'd you grow up
oh we were
romanian but it was like an immigrant
neighborhood
um so you know same if you don't finish
your plate that's disrespectful to the
people who made the food how's the food
in italy i feel like uh the carbs thing
is too much very yeah i think very
overrated in my opinion so i'm actually
not supposed to eat gluten because i
have an allergy yeah but i was in italy
and it's you know gluten galore so i was
actually eating a lot of it and it was
very interesting because i didn't get
sick while i was in italy but i do while
i'm in the u.s
so somehow
the food was actually maybe more okay
for me to digest which i appreciated but
i didn't like it as much as i thought
did you like the food there yeah
no
it's uh i did i did i love cars but it's
um
it's it feels like vegas when when i go
there for the food it's like if i stay
here
too long i'm gonna do things i regret
that's what it feels like with the food
right i don't know how to moderate and
everybody is pushing very large portions
and wild kind of eating things on you
uh pasta
pizza and it's so good and bread
so delicious so
yeah i i love it but i regret everything
so it's like i don't want to i don't
want to go to a place where
um i'm going to regret everything i do
for too long of a time
yeah surprisingly the people there
though are still very fit and everyone
stays in good shape but that's probably
because you're walking around all day
and you're much more active than
anything and they also just know how to
moderate food i think i got used to the
u.s way of eating the u.s porsche what
is that
just a lot
never always a lot yeah and more and i
feel in the u.s food advertisements are
also much more in your face and you're
more often reminded of junk food than we
were in italy so even though you're
eating less healthy things i think we're
getting cravings and being pushed
towards junk food less often
all right i got to ask you a hard
question
uh so the romance languages so i think
french is up there as like number one
number one in terms of i don't know this
was ranking them
oh you guys speak italian or no not
italian but we studied french and
spanish in school
and romanian i feel like every country
calls their language a romance like no
but it's romanian french spanish
portuguese
um and i think there was one more that
was like this dialect but those are
considered the romance languages okay so
where would you put italian i think we
got yelled at i'm so
it's on the bottom of the list because
people did not use it nicely but i
always really liked how french sounds
um
i i think something about it where maybe
spanish actually sounds nicer to the
ears but french has more character and
it feels more sultry so i like french
that was my answer too oh sultry okay
yeah
i feel like uh french well in france i
feel like i'm always being judged
like they're better than me that's what
friends they are better yeah
this is so true
uh which is why you know yeah i long to
belong to that i like the british accent
the british really yeah actually one
thing we did on our italian trip is we
just picked up british accents for the
entire trip for fun
and we forgot we were doing them to the
point where we talked to british people
and they just ask us why are you talking
like that i just couldn't stop i i did
feel much more elegant and mature true
people like you know i don't know if
they felt the same way about us but it
was more of you know the confidence
you do feel like you're more poised for
sure yeah
so how'd you guys get into chess
when when did you first let's say when
did you first fall in love with chess
so we both started playing when we were
pretty young around six years old that's
when our dad taught us and
i enjoyed playing chess because i had
good results early on but a lot of it
was being pushed from my dad to play
chess and i only really started loving
it when we moved from canada and we
started moving a lot and chess was the
one stable thing that i had and it was
also where all my
uh friends were so it was kind of that
foundational thing for me
and that's when i started studying chess
very intensely and when i started
putting in the hours out of my own will
not because i was being pushed by my dad
that's when i started really loving it
and i even wanted to take time off
college to just focus on chess
so training and competing training and
competing yeah it was when i was doing
it for myself that i started getting my
best results
and actually enjoying the thing and
really enjoying it yeah i would spend
summer vacation studying for tournaments
and my mom would come and say you need
to make friends go leave the house and
i'd be like no i need to play chess and
i i remember those moments that you
rebelled by playing chess yeah exactly
how did you get into it yeah my my
experience with
loving in high school is very opposite
from alex's but right my sister was
playing and my dad taught me when i was
andrea was cool in high school unlike me
you are uh i i wouldn't say cool i'd
save more balance and i was interested
in other hobbies in my childhood if i
ever really did love chess there's
certainly moments about like traveling
and being together with my family and
spending those moments together but
those are more the social and the
experiences but funny enough like i
think my happiest moment where i really
played the game for my own enjoyment was
probably my most recent tournament
because this was after obviously we've
been streaming and i'm no longer in high
school but when i was in school i was
always playing for college and for the
results trying to build a resume so i
was too stressed out about the pressure
to really enjoy the game whereas when i
just played my first tournament so it
was like
after like a two-year break because of
the pandemic um and it was also all live
on twitch so there was some pressure but
it was the first time that like i was
really eager to study for the game
sitting and focusing since we've been
streaming and not getting distracted by
something else in years like i said and
the tournament experience i hit my
highest rating and it was my best
tournament ever and i think most of that
is because it came from my own enjoyment
so
you didn't enjoy the domination because
i think you like did really well right
this is like a couple months ago uh oh
yeah yeah the tournament well of course
i think the results came from enjoying
the tournament because i would be in
high school like studying double triple
the amount of time like six hours every
day compared to this tournament i didn't
even prepare for it and for three years
i wouldn't be able to pass one rating
whereas in this one term and i passed it
by like 70 points without even any
preparation so it was i think as soon as
you stop worrying about the competitions
when the games get much better what does
it mean to pass a rating so i was stuck
at 1900. 1900 is 100 points off of
expert yeah
usually when you reach 2000 you're
considered an expert which is the rating
andre i was going for okay expert that's
the technical term or this like
it's more of a colloquial term where if
somebody's around a 2000 you're playing
them in a tournament they won't have the
actual title next to their name but you
say i'm playing an expert what about
like the the more official things like
master that have to do with the ratings
yeah so national master in the us is
when you're 2200.
okay and what's international master
international master is based off of a
different system the fide system which
is international to be an international
master it's
2400 and you have to have three
international master norms
yeah i think magnus said he's uh 28 6
something
that was yeah and then he said uh that's
pretty decent
no well he always uh but the thing is i
think what he meant
is
that's a decent rating because it
accurately captures his actual level
so it's uh it's not over inflated or
underinflated and so on
and so the discussion there was how do
you get can a human being get to 2900
and then he says because my current
rating is pretty decent
representing my skill level it's gonna
be a long road to actually get there
right because it's like
so you have to beat people your same
level that's how the number increases
exactly
yeah and you beat a bunch of people in
the tournament right that are higher
than that very lucky oh i was playing i
was really nervous because my category
was like 200 points above my rating and
of course
i was very rusty and i hadn't played a
tournament in a while but it went pretty
well
do you feel the pressure when you're
actually recording it like the streaming
it was
definitely so before every round i was
vlogging and i was doing meet and greets
and doing other things for them that's
how you do a meet and greet you didn't
know what the hell you're doing is great
yeah like where am i how do i do this
yeah i see
what do i do it was actually really
wholesome the beginning was um very
silly because i was just not expecting
that it was going to be more of a
seminar i thought it was like oh you
pose and take pictures but they actually
asked really nice meaningful questions
but unfortunately it's bad for youtube
retention and we cut them all out so
bad for you
the good long-form conversation so it
was like questions q a type of thing
exactly you have to have very fast pace
for youtube and um that seminar was not
fast-paced okay well not everything in
life needs to be on youtube right
there's like two parallel things stuff
that's fun for youtube yes and one day
we'll post that q a one yeah when you
guys like when you become like ultra
famous you're currently just regular
famous
q and a slow
content yes
and that the youtube aspect the creation
aspect does that add to the fun
ultimately how's the chess of like your
love of chess oh for the love of chess
in general or just for competing in that
one tournament no love with just in
general i i think you said that for
competing for that tournament was adding
pressure yeah but actually i would say
like a good pressure but yeah this is
where i differed to alex because
um when i was just competitive and i was
younger
i don't think i loved chess as much as
when i started doing it for content
because unlike her a lot of her friends
and social circle
other chess players i never really
traveled and built really solid
friendships through chess until i
started streaming and meeting other
chess streamers and
actually playing and talking to people
for fun rather than just always being
alone in the game and never really
meeting other people my age or people
with similar interests so i would say
twitch was the thing that
really changed how i approached the game
i think with uh with some youtubers
there's a pressure to be almost somebody
else you create a persona and you're
stuck in that persona i think
um i'm
too i'm too much of a boomer to know
what the hell twitch is anyway but the
it feels like when you're actually live
streaming
you can't help but be who you really are
i think it's oh well i think when you're
live streaming and i've talked to a lot
of other streamers about this
you kind of just over exaggerate one
side of your personality and of course
it's kind of like being like on all the
time like you're trying to be more
entertaining and sometimes you're being
sillier at moments or
more
you take what character traits like
people know you for and for me one is
being like adhd and the younger sibling
who's very energetic and causes trouble
even though yeah i'm sure you caused
trouble just for the camera yeah right
i think yeah i think
and of course once you're live streaming
for like four or five hours there's
gonna be moments in the stream where
it's more chill but especially when
you're like editing that content or
you're doing bigger streams that are
shorter
you are kind of playing up a side of
yourself because of course there's a lot
of parts of me that i don't show to the
camera because they're not as
entertaining to watch like the more
serious part and also there's things
that you are really interested in about
what you do like i love competitive
chess where i could sit and really think
about it but i know that that is not
going to be as entertaining for stream i
know that's not going to be as
entertaining for youtube so you kind of
have to take what you like but then
really adapt it for whatever the format
is and sometimes that feels inauthentic
uh but other times it just feels like
repackaging what you love for people
in a more general audience to enjoy do
you feel like it's a trap a little bit
as you evolve like uh
oh i think social media oh sorry go
ahead social media in general is a trap
of that of that kind
well so we've been trying to switch to
learn how to make youtube videos
recently and so much of learning youtube
school is kind of the beastification of
content where you try to get to the
point of the video within like the first
10 seconds to not lose people you try to
take it you mean like mr beast yeah okay
yeah where it's so fast-paced there's a
reason to wait there's high stakes
and everything is created to keep people
watching the video and keep people on
the platform and in some ways it is a
trap because it's harder to do
the kind of content you like because you
really have to squeeze it to be like
okay well
do we have a good thumbnail for this do
we have a good title for this um and
that's something that we're trying to
figure out how
to
keep true to what we want to do yeah see
the way i think about it is yeah there's
a lot of stuff you can create and yeah
the mr bestification process
but also
i think about what are the videos
conversations or things i will create in
this life
that will be
the best thing i do
and um i try not to do things
in my life that will prevent me from
getting there i feel like if you're
always focusing on um
doing kind of the optimizing the
thumbnail in the 10 seconds and so on
you'll never do the thing that's truly
you're known for and remembered for so
finding that balance is tricky i get
that but at the same time this might be
my own copium which i know is a word you
know now
yeah i'm slowly learning the complexity
of the term yes um but
the other way i think about it is
it is the skill to learn how to
communicate with large audiences
and
first i started streaming chess which is
something i just did and really loved
but now i have to learn how to translate
that format and if that's a skill set we
could build then we could use it to do
really important things
and i've seen a lot of youtubers who
have done interviews about how you know
they didn't love the kind of content
they did at at first but what they're
doing right now is really meaningful so
i like to think of it maybe like skill
development because not everybody hits
off podcasts where they can talk to
super interesting people right off the
bat yeah you can be slow and boring in a
podcast you don't have to worry about
the first 10 seconds i mean people like
keep pushing me for because but the
first 10 seconds of the videos
i do is well i know it's most important
for youtube but i don't give a damn i
wrote a chrome extension that hides all
the views and likes i don't look at the
the the click i don't look at twitch
views andrea does so we also can relate
i love numbers too but that's why i
don't look at it because you become like
oh i
you'll start to think that a
conversation or a thing you did sucks
because it doesn't get views yeah but
that's just not the case
the youtube algorithm is this monster
that figures stuff out and if you let it
control your mind i feel like it's going
to destroy you creatively so you have to
find a nice balance i have to say i was
laughing a little bit when i was
listening to the magnus episode and the
first 10 minutes you guys are talking
about soccer football two robots seem
like humans yeah
i was like let's have some fun a
conversation about non-chess related
topics yeah talk about sports yeah it
was kind of hilarious i was surprised
that
uh even at his level
i wasn't sure but i was surprised how
much he loves chess it sounds cliche to
say but like the way he looked at a
chess board you know those memes like i
wish somebody looked at me in the way
he's still like the way he glanced down
and he reached for the pieces with
excitement to show me something there
was there wasn't like
uh okay i'll show you it was like
like there was still that fire
that's something that always shocks me
about some of like super grand masters
like one of my coaches was a person who
also his name's jim hammer of norway he
also coached
magnus he was his second and he was
helping me train for my tournament and i
was kind of putting off doing the
homework he's like if you're putting it
off that means you're studying the wrong
thing like you should be enjoying even
when you're practicing which when i grew
up i thought to get to the top level
like practicing has to be hard and
unpleasant and when i was listening to
magnus episode he was like i didn't read
books very much or it there's one thing
that you said that's like very normal
for studying classical chess that he
didn't do just because it didn't
interest him he says i suck at puzzles i
don't like puzzles yeah and he doesn't
do what he doesn't enjoy and that's
because it's like purely driven out of
passion i think the internet was like i
suck at puzzles too yeah they like that
i don't have to study at all it's just
it's fun and uh but i think the lesson
there that's really powerful is he
spends most of the day thinking about
chess because he wants to yeah so do
whatever if you're into getting better
chess to whatever it takes
to actually just the number of hours you
spend a day thinking about chess
maximize that if you're like super
serious about it i actually get very
addicted whenever i start studying chess
which is why i don't do it as seriously
when i'm focused on content uh because i
go through these rabbit holes where if
i'm focusing on chess i want to be as
good as i possibly can at the game
otherwise it's hard for me to enjoy it
because it's such a competitive thing
and i remember training for tournaments
and when you're training for tournaments
you even start dreaming about chess and
you can't stop thinking about it and
it's as if you're flipped into this
completely different world which is also
what i like best about the game that
it's a completely different living
experience and then you take some drugs
and now you start to see things on the
ceiling is there some factual um
hallucination like
uh to the uh queen's gambit like those
scenes uh i think it's is that based on
your life story from well i can't say
that on camera no just kidding um
actually chess players are very careful
to not take drugs they drink a lot yeah
they drink so much it's actually crazy
for how good they're able to play chess
when they do
but when it comes to things like
psychedelics or other things they
usually stay away from those because
they don't want to mess anything up in
their brain so this is actually an
intervention i've i saw that you
mentioned somewhere i think was the lie
detector test where you have a drinking
problem
is that actual i think i think that's
actually um a meme that we like to joke
about on stream because occasionally
we'd have like a white claw on stream or
something like that and then people meme
about it it goes back to andrea's point
of amplifying a part of your personality
to make yourself a little bit right more
entertaining you could use that as an
excuse from now on i'm just this podcast
is just amplifying a part of that person
now i'm not really like this
uh but have you played drunk like magnus
has played drunk he says it helps him
with the creativity is there any truth
to that well andrea is under 21 so she's
obviously would never do it never do
that um but i have played while drinking
actually
i enjoy playing jess chess and drinking
more than pre-gaming or going out to a
club and drinking which sounds really
silly and i'll usually play against
opponents who are also you know having
some beer
and
it does make you feel like you're seeing
the game from a fresher perspective
where it
can sometimes make you feel more
confident liquid confidence and it does
help with creativity you just feel like
you could pull things off um but there's
also a limit it's more like you've had
one drink or two drink but then it goes
beyond that and then you just start
missing tactics and it's not worth it
yeah i think it only helps players in
very short time controls one time i was
challenging this grandmaster on stream
and we were playing bullet chess which
is one minute chess and i was giving him
handicaps and i said okay you have to
take four shots before the next game and
he just got like 10 times stronger and
transformed into like the hulk and
destroyed me more than the last game so
but of course if you're playing like a
three-hour game it's gonna get old but i
think in short time controls it's
amazing yeah it does definitely has to
be blitz it has to be where it's more
intuition rather than sitting in
calculus this is probably like
negatively affecting your ability to
calculate absolutely
how much when you guys play when you
look at the chess board how much of it
is calculation how much of it is
intuition how much of it is memorized
openings
um
it really depends between short form
chess so five minutes three minutes one
minute and classical chess what's your
favorite to play i love playing blitz
now because that's most of what i do and
that's actually how i got into chess
streaming because i couldn't spend
entire weekends or weeks playing
tournaments i would just while i was in
college log on and play these long blitz
or bullet sessions and it's very fast so
you don't have time to go
calculate as deeply you basically have
to calculate short lines pretty quickly
and a lot of it is pattern recognition
and intuition um that's three minutes
you said three minutes yeah okay cool
and so for that it's just it's basically
intuition a lot of it is intuition yeah
see i saw on the streams you actually
keep talking while playing chess it
seems like yeah that's my result that
doesn't help my results it doesn't help
the content not the game yeah exactly
but you can still do it because i i it
feels like how can you possibly
concentrate while talking it's because
so much of it is intuition you're not
while you're talking you're thinking
about that topic but then you just come
to the board and you just understand
what you should be doing here and then
sometimes you get in trouble because
you're talking and you have now lost
half of your time you have a minute and
a half your opponent has three and
you're kind of at a disadvantage um
but that kind of goes to show that
that's how blitz chess usually works
whereas classical is very different
which of you is better at chess i mean
let's do it this way can you
um andrea can you say
what is
in which way is alex stronger than you
which way is she weaker than you not
physically in in terms of the ch in
terms of chess
um
well yes of course she is higher rated
but when we do play
um i think her strengths against me
where she really gets me is the end game
she has stronger end games so she can
and i actually have a stronger opening
um but as soon as she's i'm supposed to
say what is good about you not you
yeah i'm getting there well see this is
the same because don't worry it's
related okay because if i can i can get
an advantage in the beginning of the
game but as soon as she starts trading
pieces down like my confidence drops
because i know that the end game is the
hardest part of the game and the longest
and that's where she ends up beating me
so her end game is her
i think really what makes a difference
and she sounds like her
psychological warfare is better too
because if you're getting nervous that
is that but it's harder to play against
higher rated players same how you know
magnus and former world championship
champions have that psychological edge
so i think it's always going to be
different for andrea because she knows
statistically she should be winning
something like one in four games but she
usually does better than that because
she's very distracting and talks a lot
that does help what does it feel like to
play a higher rated player
what's the experience of that
in like uh
playing somebody like magnus
so it depends on how much higher rated
than you they are if it's someone who's
like between me and andrea let's say
it's a 200 point difference
you know they should win but at least
you still feel like you have a chance i
was playing in uh title tuesday which is
this tournament chess.com has every
tuesday and i got really lucky beat a gm
drew an international master and then i
got paired against hikaru nakamura and
my brain just went blank because the i
just know that i'm so unlikely to win
that i couldn't even play the game
properly when it's that much of a
difference where they should be winning
like 99 of the time
but that's like psychological so you're
saying that's the biggest experience
it's like
actually knowing the numbers and
statistically thinking there's no way i
can win but i meant like is there a
suffocating feeling like positionally
you feel like you're constantly
under attack
you just feel like you're slowly getting
outsmarted and the worst is when you
don't even know what you're doing wrong
you come out of that you're like
i thought i was doing great and i got
slowly squeezed i didn't understand what
was going on and you're just kind of
baffled it's kind of like watching alpha
zero beat up stock fish and you don't
really understand why it's making
certain moves or how it thought of the
plan you just see it slowly getting the
position better and that's what it feels
like i i would add
it's kind of different for me if they're
someone who's significantly higher rated
so let's say more than like 300 points
or you're playing magnus
what i notice is i just feel lost
straight as soon as i don't know my
preparation because they know so many
opening lines that they're going to know
the best line to beat you that you
haven't studied so then on move 10
you're like he already has a maybe plus
.5 advantage which is really small but
for someone with such a significant
skill level you know you already lost at
that point and it's like a third of the
game
what are the strengths and weaknesses of
andrea
andrea is very good at opening
preparations as she said as she said she
likes bringing that up i mean she's very
meticulous about it where she'll really
go in and learn her lines
and having that initial starting
confidence isn't just helpful for the
opening but it helps develop your plans
for the middle game so i think she's
very good at that
um i think she's actually pretty good at
tactical
combinations um what is tactics tactics
is like solving puzzles
um or basically finding lines that are
forced where if you find them you're
going to win
so that's like puzzles within a with
yeah exactly whereas strategic chess is
making slow moves and over the process
of like 20 moves you get a slightly
better position based on
an understanding of the overall strategy
so in my extensive research review on
wikipedia
it says your most played opening is the
king's indian defense
in which quote black allows white to
advance their pawns to the center of the
board
in the first two moves i is there any
truth to this
so
the kings and what is it probably is my
most played opening um
and it's one where even when my coach
who was a grandmaster taught me he's
like so you know i've been playing the
king's indian for 10 years and i still
don't understand it and it's one of
those openings that computers really
don't like because you do or at least
stockfish doesn't like it maybe alpha
zero would change their mind i forgot to
look at what can you show me by the way
what it is yeah
is it uh
is it white's opening or black something
black responds to uh the d4 queen's pawn
push and you take your knight out to f6
i'll just put in the you know
stereotypical
classical king's indian more so to say
um
so we actually have a very famous king's
indian game in the notes that we
prepared okay
for the record i asked you guys for one
some games that you find pretty cool and
well maybe to get a chance to talk about
something yeah um so this is the king's
indian as you can see
white has much more control over the
center white has three pawns in the
center while black has none past the
fifth rank and you just have this pawn
on d6 and one of the ideas in chess is
if you're not taking the center then
your plan revolves around trying to
continually challenge it
but what is really fun about the king's
indian is that black sometimes gets
these crazy king side attacks while
white gets queen side attacks and even
though
it's a little bit suspicious for black
and the computer could usually break it
it's hard to defend as a human when
you're being attacked but if you don't
pull off the attack as black then you're
just gonna end up being lost in the end
game so it's like a very asymmetrical
position it's very asymmetrical although
a lot of people now stop playing into
the classical kings indian even though
computers give it a big advantage and
they play these slower lines in the
king's indian which are less fun to play
what's slower mean it takes a longer
time to like
do something interesting with um
they basically don't let you get as much
of a kingside attack because they try
opening up the center and then you have
no weaknesses but you're just slowly
improving the position of your pieces
instead of being able to go for that
king side attack so for people just
listening there is a the
white pawns are all on the fourth row in
a row together that feels like a bad
position for black for white
oh you don't like taking the center no i
like taking the center so this is now
you're talking trash around oh sorry but
like
they're just like they're like feel
vulnerable they're in a row together
like it's like uh like a you know
because they're like who's gonna defend
them i guess the nice defender when the
queen defends it that you're actually
talking about a theme that you do see
sometimes which is called hanging pawns
when you have two pawns right next to
each other with no other pawns to defend
them yeah um so it it is a value valid
point and actually as black you're
trying to break apart these pawns or get
them to push and create some holes into
the position
but it's
a trade-off and that's a lot of what
chess openings are about
you get more space but you'll also end
up having to protect your pawns
potentially or move them forward to the
point where they're overextended and
plus pawns being vulnerable it's kind of
fun this it's like there's more stuff in
danger they're not because if it's if
it's like this everything's like trapped
like you can't do anything everything's
blocked yeah blocked off yeah because
you can't have fun yeah
the the
one of the most one of the opening
principles for white is get your pawns
in the center so i'd say
like this is actually preferable for
white go let's go over some opening
principles there we go because this is a
very good learning okay
in the audience
okay so first thing you want to do is
control the center
there you go e4 the more aggressive one
isn't that like the the basic vanilla
move i didn't uh somebody told me that's
the most popular
opening move in chess it is why is that
considered aggressive so the two it's e4
and d4 and the king's pawn is known as
being for more tactical players whereas
d4 is known for more positional players
so that's why it's considered more
aggressive
gambits with e4 i think so tactical
means
i'm i'm gonna try to attack you
you're gonna try to go for puzzles and
rely more on your um
combination abilities
uh whereas if it's something positional
you usually have like three to four
moves that are all good in the position
whereas tactics you need to see this one
line
so it's more precise so this this one's
cool because he can like you know the
queen can come out the bishop can come
out yeah and that's uh
one of the most popular checkmates and
usually what you teach new students to
try to cheese their friends because then
they feel really excited that they know
this new trap where you bring the bishop
and the queen out and you try to check
mate on f7 yeah it's the trap that uh
queen's gambit beth harmon falls for
nerf like first game versus the janitor
she gets all mad because she gets
checkmated very early that's the one she
gets checkmated with yeah okay i love
how you guys were actually paying
attention to the games carefully
uh which is pretty cool that they did a
good job of
improving evolving her game throughout
the show to actually
represent an actual growth of a chess
player yeah they they really
took every detail into consideration
which was cool okay so what what else
that's that's i brought stuff
okay
so then you want to develop your pieces
so in the beginning of the game you want
to take out the bishops and knights
first because you don't want to start
with the most valuable piece like the
queen
because then it'll become a
vulnerability and it'll get attacked
very early on
and the reason you're taking up these
two pieces first is because you want to
castle your king so you can move a night
move or a bishop move and that's
considered developing yeah so if at this
stage not
like even before getting a few pawns out
you usually
want to start with getting a pawn
because you want to get space in the
center but also when you push pawns it
helps free up some of your pieces
um
so usually start with one pawn first and
then you can start taking out your minor
pieces which is the bishop in the night
i have anxiety about a pawn just
floating out there
defenseless but i'm not attacked yet
it's a see those are what you call ghost
threats so you're scared of something
that hasn't happened yet so if i were to
attack it i feel like there's a deeper
thing going on here
actually let's say
yes so you're attacking the pawn in the
center here and it is vulnerable but as
soon as you do that
i can develop my own knight and defend
it as well
okay and now for people just listening
there's two pawns that just came out to
meet each other and a couple of nights
we love the chess card
the pawns met after midnight yeah yeah
i'm gonna romanticize the game a bit
exactly uh okay cool so
so like there's uh
if you bring out the bishops with the
knights you're matching that with the
other uh the black is going to match it
whatever you're attacking with yeah
can't defend it i could develop your
bishop or your knight whatever you'd
like
oh no now you gave him options oh right
yeah
there you go
now i am attacking the pawn in the
center which is what you were afraid
about before but let's see how you
defend it here
by doing this symmetrical thing bringing
out the knight on the other side and
actually your other move was good as
well defending with the pawn because
then you're freeing up space for your
bishop so you're basically trying to
develop your pieces as quickly as
possible put your pawns in the center
and then get your king to safety and
that's usually the basic opening tips
that you get it is kind of
counterintuitive that safety is in the
corner of the board for kings
that was always confusing to me but you
know three pawns in front though you
typically don't push those
maybe like one maybe i'll go one square
but
these are will be like the wall of
defense that keep them safe but another
way to also think about it is um your
pieces usually want to point towards the
center if you have a knight closer to
the center then closer to the side it
actually has more squares it can go to
so a huge part of it is just wanting to
have flexibility for where your pieces
go so more pieces are going to be able
to make threats in the center or even
open up the position so since that's
where it's most likely
to open you want your king somewhere
where the position will stay closed so
that you have the pawns to defend you
know there is like rules like this but i
always wonder because i build chess
engines but then
you start to wonder like why is it that
positionally these things are good like
you've built up an intuition about it
but i wish and that's the thing that
would be amazing if engines could
explain
why is this kind of thing better than
this kind of thing you start to build up
an intuition but if i'm just like know
nothing about chess it feels confusing
that cornering your king
like getting them
uh
like trapped here like it feels like you
could get check made it easier there if
i was just using like dumb intuition but
it seems like that's not the case
i imagine maybe because alpha zero
learned by playing games against itself
right yeah and i imagine if you have a
lot of games then you do build intuition
because if you were to keep your king in
the center you just see that in those
games you're dealing with threats a lot
more often
um but yeah they're shortcut rules and
this doesn't even mean it's the best way
to play chess as we've seen with
alpha zero kind of changing the rules of
the game a little bit but as a human
to learn it from scratch is a lot more
difficult than to start with principles
so that's why beginners usually learn
chess this way
yeah but because you're playing other
humans and the other humans have also
operated under different principles and
that's why
people that come up now that are
training with engines
are just going to be much better at than
the people of the past because they're
going to have they're going to try out
weirder ideas that go against the
principles of old right and they're
gonna do like weird stuff including
sacrifices and stuff like that yeah and
i also think that's why alpha zero was
so shocking because stockfish was using
an opening database so it was already
based off of knowledge that humans have
from playing chess for years that we
just thought is how you're supposed to
play whereas alpha zero just learned
from playing the game so many times and
came up with very novel opening ideas
were you impressed by alpha have you
have you seen some of the games i have
seen some of the games i think
impressed bewildered
and uh motivated were the three things i
experienced i think magnus said uh he
was also impressed that
it could easily be mistaken for
creativity that's this trash talk
towards the ai that was a beautiful
sentence i i was listening to the
podcast
i mean
as a human i agree with him because you
don't want to give the machine the the
power of creativity but
if it looks creative
get give it give it a compliment that's
that's fair
i know that you're being nice to the
machines in case they are ever looking
back through this
what else is there what other principles
are there for the um the opening you can
go a little bit
more forward let's say and yeah we can
finish full of development positions
like this
let's just say you developed all of your
pieces
um
so that's like a really nice
like nobody nobody took any pieces and
we're just in a nice positional thing
yeah so it's not actually a very
accurate yes
i could put a different one on the board
but usually after you've developed all
of your pieces
um you want to get your queen out a
little bit to connect your rooks and you
also start thinking about certain pawn
pushes and getting more space
but another good tip is just can you
improve the position of your pieces
think about timing so if you've already
moved a piece once and there's a piece
that hasn't moved at all then you want
to focus on the piece that hasn't moved
at all
to be able to have it more likely to
jump into the game right so don't move
pieces multiple times exactly like try
to move it to the most optimal position
yeah yeah that makes sense what uh
so what's the indian so i think we kind
of went over it but why did you ever say
why you like it so much because that's
weird because it's king-sized i liked it
because it's a very fun aggressive
defense where you're just throwing your
pieces towards white and there's so many
sacrificing opportunities
and for some reason tactical games
always feel like the most beautiful the
most satisfying and that's what i liked
about the king's indian but i also
suffered a lot from this this love
because i would play things that are not
necessarily correct then my attack
wouldn't pan out and i would just
struggle the rest of the game having no
play and just trying to defend so if
you're always a wikipedia also says that
that you're known for your attacking
play
it's also known for losses according to
stanford okay let's not bring see
wikipedia doesn't talk trash
a lot nicer um i actually
played a lot of positional chess in
classic because i really like the slow
squeeze
but when i transition to playing a lot
of online chess it's
almost as if i was looking for more
instant gratification because it feels
so much better to beat someone with an
attack and even if sometimes it doesn't
pan out i was okay with it because you
get so many games in
so i think my style in online chess
really changed for my classical chess
what about you andrea do you have a
style are you attacking are you uh more
like conservative defensive player
are you chaotic opening wise i like to
play more positionally like i like to
push d4 and just slowly improve my
pieces and slowly get an attack but like
alex said if you're playing bullet chess
or blitz against viewers you often like
wanna
play riskier moves that may not be as
good and then that's kind of when i
would play more aggressive but i do
enjoy tournaments for that reason
because then
like once her 15 moves in which as soon
as you're out of your prep i like
sitting and thinking in more positional
um
yeah positional middle games one of the
games you found to be pretty cool is the
uh hakara nakamura versus golf on in
2009. and that one i think includes the
king's indian defense yes um what's
what's why is that an interesting one to
you i also played the king's indian as
black and i loved this model game but
and as alex was saying like all these
advantages for the king's indian but now
there's this one line
that like every higher rated player just
destroys my king's indian and you see
these beautiful games they're like oh
yes i want to play for these ideas but
now no one plays into it anymore and you
just get demolished so this is why i
don't play the kings indeed anymore but
not to ruin the fun right the love hate
relationship truly the reality but
that's like the higher level players do
or does everybody yeah if you're
studying openings and you know this line
as white you just you automatically get
the upper edge and that's kind of how
openings develop you start having
players trying new lines and then you
see ones and then everybody adopts it if
they think it's the best one but yeah so
hikaru is really known for his
aggressive style of play
black hero yeah hikaru is black here so
he's playing the king's indian
and as you can see in this position
white already has a lot a huge center
advantage but what hikaru is going to
start doing even with the next move is
bringing all of his pieces towards the
white king side because his plan is to
start pushing his pawns towards the
white king and this ignore the attacks
that's a great example of a dream attack
with the king's indian so there's a
complete asymmetry towards the king side
on the left side of the board is a ton
of pieces yeah exactly um
wow he moved the night like three times
in a row
and that's what you need to do because
you have to move the knight in order to
make space for your pawn so again this
is why it's so counter-intuitive and
stockfish doesn't like it you're putting
almost most of your pieces on the back
rank and you're pushing your king side
pawns and you're blocking your own dark
squared bishop so none of it makes sense
you're mimicking it that's awesome um
okay so yeah here you see white going
for queen side attack black going for
the king side attack and you can keep
going a little bit and i'll wait to
where he starts with the pretty
sacrifices
it's more fun to analyze games in person
than on the computer i think yeah okay
okay so here hikaru is preparing the
attack and what i really like about this
game is that he finds these tactics that
are not necessarily what a computer
would go for but it's very hard to face
as a human and that's why a lot of
people play the king's indian because in
in practice it's hard to defend against
so we can keep moving a little bit
forward
okay
yep so white is just continuing the king
side plan now it's the first is that
like the first piece i think that's
taken in the game yep that's the first
trade so it begins exactly hikaru had to
pause his attack for a little bit to
just make sure that white didn't have
two dire threats on the queen side so
cool to see the asymmetry of this thing
exactly that's what's beautiful about
this and just one thing to highlight
because his his rook move here is very
bizarre and typically like a computer
probably didn't like this but the ideas
are very interesting because this is a
major weakness for black that they're
coming to attack and he's also making
room for his bishop to come backwards
and challenge so this is like a
human-like maneuver that computer i
think computers would like this though
because you have you'd have to move it
regardless because he has he takes the
pawn here and his rook would be under
attack yeah well have you looked at it
when i actually studied this as a line
and this right away isn't the best move
current computer so actually that's a
good question did you guys when you
study games use your own mind but do you
also use computers to
build up your intuition of like looking
at a position like this and what would a
computer do and then try to understand
why it wants to do that when i was
studying seriously i would try to use my
own mind because you're never going to
get the exact same position so you
really need to notice trends and often
computers will give you moves that are
only specific to that position because
of a certain tactic
um but i do use computers to check what
i did and make sure i didn't make any
obvious blunder that i might have missed
what does a computer tell you just like
what what is the best move or does it
give you
any kind of explanation of why it
doesn't tell you why but it gives you
the different valuations of the position
like black is
down a half pawn here or something like
that um but it hints you towards what
the right move is and then it's on you
to figure out why and you could usually
figure out why if not right away than
just by going through a few moves and
being like oh okay that makes sense i
feel like a computer will take you down
with some weird lines potentially
like sacrifice like why the hell am i
sacrificing this
well we'll get to the pretty sacrifice
soon um
so we could just keep playing bonds are
being pushed forward yeah
and hikaru is kind of ignoring the queen
side attack here um they basically both
only reply to each other's plan when
they have to
this is where you convert all the
podcast viewers to youtube yeah they
have no idea what we're talking about
right now there is a zen like experience
of just like listening and imagining the
board just imagine the pieces on the
ceiling yeah you should we should be
calling them out and then people will be
freaking out even more am i supposed to
keep track of what the position is
how hard is blindfold just have you
tried like are you able to keep them
i've played blindfold chest before um
for me it's pretty hard it's not a
muscle that i've trained as much and i'm
very visual when it comes to chess um
but it is one as a top player that
starts becoming very second nature for
you actually this is what
i talked to magnus about this
um maybe i was again influenced by
queen's gambit what do you actually
visualize when it's in your head
so for magnus it was a boring 2d board
right are you do you have some kind of
that's every chess player no you don't
have like because you know some chess
like uh computer games you can do all
kinds of skins and like yeah like fancy
stuff you don't have anything sadly i
don't have like a cool 3d warrior mode
on it's just a chess baseboard in my
head
because you don't yeah you can't use
your brain power for adding colors to it
because you already have to keep track
of the pieces it's one board at a time
yes okay the current position yeah i bet
every chest i wonder if there's any who
there's certain players who are really
good and they can even play blindfold
chess and play multiple games at the
same time um
so i would be curious how they do it but
usually when you're thinking of one game
that's the only one
in your mind yeah but you have to do
this operation where you move one piece
you're doing like the branch analysis
like yeah
and so
uh you still have to somehow visualize
the the branching process
um and not forget stuff maybe that's
like constant memory recall or something
you're always looking one board at a
time but and you're also oh because
you're also looking in the future yeah
yeah and then you have to backtrack
you're keeping the position in your
memory so you're remembering where all
the pieces are and then you're playing
it out on one board and then you can
come back to the initial one that you
started with that you kind of just keep
in your brain and it's also easier to
come back to it once you've played a
position from it
i feel like it's that
memory recall
that gets you to blunder so i'll like
see that i'm being attacked by certain
things
but then because i get so exhausted
thinking about a different thing i
forget i actually forget about an entire
branch of things that i was supposed to
be worried about it happens very often
yeah if you spend a bunch of time
calculating in a position let's say like
when you're really in trouble and you're
spending 15 20 minutes calculating
you'll forget about something that you
spotted like oh if i do these two three
moves i'll walk into a trap because
you've looked at so many lines and then
you play it and then you see it and
you're like oh i i looked at it and i
saw it but i forgot about it yeah
it's often called tunneling where you're
just looking so deeply on one thing you
forget about the rest of the board
and it's the worst when at least in a
beginner level there's like a
i don't know a bishop just sitting there
obviously attacking your like queen or
something and then you just forget that
bishop exists
because if they just sit there for a few
moves and don't move
you just forget their existence and then
it's just yeah that's that's definitely
very embarrassing well it happens to
everyone so
yes
um
okay cool
okay so
we see a few trades happening on the
queen side where he had to go for those
otherwise he's in trouble um and this is
where the game oh sorry
this is where he gets excited yeah so so
knight h4 is really when the sacrifice
starts
and
here
the two important pawns are the ones in
front of the king because they're
helping with the entire defense and
ikaro is actually preparing to sacrifice
his knight for a pawn
just so that he can continue his attack
and open up the position because if you
don't do that here as black and don't
get some kind of attack you are
completely lost on the queen side and
also you've pushed all of your own king
side pawns so you're going to be in
danger so it's one of those do or die
moments oh okay so that that's what
makes it all in because the king is wide
open yeah yeah the king is wide open and
you all of white's pieces are pointed
towards the queen side too where you're
also cramped so it's the attack
primarily by black done by the two pawns
and then and the knight and the light
squared bishop is always extremely
important so you don't want to trade
this in the king's indian because it's
very helpful for a lot of attacks
even though it's on the other side of
the board i guess it can go all the way
across in in
like i i'm not sure what it's doing here
but probably threatening like for
example if if it was another move black
could have played would be something
like bishop h3 where if you take the
bishop you actually get mated on g2
with what so let's say you take here and
then you could push the pawn and then it
would be checkmate
so you're kind of using your bishop to
sacrifice
against whites
king side pawns
yeah i'll be freaking out if the bishop
did that exactly what are they up to
right and that's the thing this position
looks very scary as white because all of
black's pawns are starting to come
towards you and it's one of those things
where
humans do start to worry in these
positions whereas computers obviously
can just calculate the best line and
maybe the attack doesn't go through so
you're saying the computer might say
that the white is actually a slight
favorite here yeah especially exactly
okay so then uh
white makes a little bit of room by
moving the rook right and the attack
begins
i like the commentary here
then the knight um the knight is hugging
the king and actually white can't even
take the king here because then h4 and
h3 is coming in i can't take the knight
yeah did i say king yes thank you the
knight well why can't take the knight
because why um so if white takes the
knight here then black starts pushing
his pawn to h4 with h3 incoming and the
idea of trying to defend against this
is
it looks very difficult so why just
choose it it'd be cool to watch a chess
game to experience watching it without
understanding it just for a day i feel
like i could use that to make better
content true um
okay i mean that's what getting drunk
does it
start unfortunately for chess players it
never leaves you
doesn't matter how but this is actually
a very cute move because black's queen
is under attack
but the king is so cramped that he can't
actually take it or he's going to get
checkmated by a pawn which is a sad way
to go truly yeah those pawns are doing a
lot of work here that is the king's
indian this is the king's indian player
attack of the king side pawns
yeah these pawns are like uh right so
they're the ones that are doing a lot of
the threatening right and they're also
opening up the position to bring more of
the pieces in but that
the pawns kind of help break open the
king side but they can't checkmate by
themselves so after the pawns come in
that's when you need to start bringing
in pieces as well which you will see uh
hikaru do here okay there you go he puts
more sacrifices so this was actually
another beautiful sacrifice in the game
um
but then puts the king in check with the
pawn right that and the pawn is going to
be given here for free but the idea is
you're giving your own peace because you
want to have more space and open up the
king which is what you're always trying
to do when you have a king side you're
trying to remove as many of the king's
defenders as you can without giving up
too much and then you have a ton of
pieces on the king's side for black
just waiting to
exactly to do harm and then uh and
notice how every single move white is
getting attacked like they're just never
getting a break black just keeps
throwing all their so it's funny that
black's queen has been hanging for like
three moves now and white still can't do
anything about it yeah so rock puts the
king in check yep the king runs
and then again we leave the queen
hanging and you develop a piece the
slight squared bishop that's so
important and you're once again
threatening checkmate on g2
and then bishop's coming to yeah again
the queen hanging i think and i mean the
game is just so beautiful the amount of
calculation hikaru put into this
position it feels like so much is in
danger right it's so interesting
and uh knight takes what upons so now
his queen is attacked twice
and
he doesn't care he takes the bishop and
he's still threatening the checkmate on
g2
and then the queen takes the bishop yep
so now he's defending against g2
and black just goes and grabs some
material back here so here black is
already is winning
well he ends up winning a night here
because black had to be so much on the
defensive he's just taking pieces yeah i
mean at this point you're up two whole
pieces so
you would yeah exactly but
and queen
queen
and then you take
and then the rook takes
and
there's not as much of an attack on the
king anymore but hikaru is up a knight
here which is gg
yeah what's the correct way of of of
saying that because i was i played uh
albus i played him in chess and then i
quickly realized
like from his facial expressions that i
should have like
stopped playing oh it was like it's
already set yeah and then he's like
like this is the good time to like give
up right you're not going to get to
checkmate where like this you know he
could see like the checkmate is like
five or seven moves away or something
this and uh what's the play
usually you have to resign if you're in
a position or you should
through chess etiquette resign when
you're in a position where
your opponent is definitely going to win
out of respect like if you're a piece
down
um and obviously all top grand masters
do that the only people who don't do
that is kids because their coaches play
until they get their coaches always tell
them never resign and they'll be in
hopelessly lost positions playing
against like two rooks a king and they
only have their soul king but they're
still playing on so that's a position
where it's obvious they can't win
because the kids might make errors yeah
and so might as well
that was the interesting thing about i
think game six of the previous world
championship with magnus was it the one
where he beat nap yeah the first time he
beat him where was like
he said that
i don't know how often you come across
this kind of situation he said the
engines predict the draw
yeah
but
that doesn't mean that it's going to be
a draw so you play on
hoping that you take a person into i
mean this is i guess an endgame thing
you take them to deep water and they
make a positional mistake or something i
don't i don't know when
like he from his gut knows that this is
supposed to be a draw but he still plays
on yeah i mean
that is one where it could theoretically
be a draw but it could be very hard to
defend because it's a hard technique to
know as a human and especially in that
game i know that uh nepo was also in
time pressure which makes it even harder
so in situations like that you should
always continue it's more where an
engine would give you something like
plus 10 or something where it's not just
clearly a win but anybody would know how
to win and that's where you're usually
supposed to resign
so what do you find beautiful about this
game is it the uh
the the attacking chess and just the the
asymmetry of it it's the asymmetry
and it's the fact that this is the dream
for the king's indian uh where you're
able to get a beautiful attack and
there's also those two really nice
sacrifices where
black just continuously kept putting
pressure on white's king to the point
where he was able to win material
and the best part of it is that if the
attack didn't work out black would have
been completely lost
how often does that happen by the way
like as an attacking player you like how
often do you put yourself in the
position of like
i'm screwed unless this works out on an
online chest more than i should and it's
usually when i sacrifice i know it's
either gonna work or i'm lost
and those are the most fun
positions to play usually but in
tournaments if you're doing a sacrifice
you're playing it with 100 confidence
because you're taking the time to
calculate it but yeah when you have
three minutes you don't have time so you
take a whim and you follow your
intuition or you find out later or
you're very confident it'll work and you
haven't calculated all the way until the
end but you've calculated to the point
where you have enough in exchange for
the sack and you think you could play
that position uh how do you train chess
these days
what's um
do you practice do you do deliberate
practice i mean you're in this tough
position because you're also a creator
and educator and entertainer
so
do you try to put in time of like daily
practice
i don't train chess anymore when i'm
focusing on creating i do if i'm
preparing for a tournament but back in
the day i would train very tournament
very seriously for tournaments and
the way it would work is i do opening
preparation for a specific tournament
because that's when you really need to
have those lines memorized and you could
also prepare for specific opponents and
i would do tactics to make sure i stay
sharp so those are the two things i
would do every single day for a
tournament and then mix up the rest with
like maybe some end games maybe some
positional chess so what does tactics uh
preparation looks like do you do like a
puzzle
like uh like a random puzzle thing
yeah i would just train puzzles for at
least like 30 to 60 minutes or books and
sometimes you were
and there's different kinds of puzzles
one you could train for pattern
recognition where you're supposed to go
through them very quickly and that's
just so that when you're playing the
game if your mind is tired it's still
keeping
track of things a little bit more easily
and then there's where you're practicing
your combination and those sometimes
take like 20 minutes to find because you
have to just calculate a lot and it's
more like making sure that you've
trained with that muscle but andrea is
actually very good at
finding ways to balance and still study
while also doing content yeah so what
you're able to do both
that's the hard thing i was getting very
irritated with content because i'm very
competitive i don't like playing chess
if i'm losing and if you're talking and
entertaining you're going to be losing
more games than winning so then i
started doing more training streams
where i'd bring on my coach
and one of the things that i wanted to
add to alex is training repertoire so i
do i would do daily puzzles every time
i'm streaming which helped me a lot even
if it's like there's this thing on
chess.com called puzzle rush where you
have three minutes and you just do
puzzle after puzzle where they get
incrementally harder
um and it's just a really good way to
build your pattern recognition
especially when you're rusty so i would
do that until i hit a high score and i
wouldn't play any blitz until i hit the
score that i want um but that's kind of
more like the fun part of chess studying
the very important one is actually
analyzing your losses and your
tournament games
and first you sit and you look through
your mistake yourself and try to see if
you can find the better moves and then
that's why you would check over with a
computer to see if you're right
so game analysis is also very important
which i try to do remember to give a
shout out i listened to a couple of
episodes of the perpetual chess podcast
which is pretty pretty good but what
with the whatever i listen to i remember
the per it's um
i think they really focus on
like teaching people
how to train yeah how to play how to
train all that kind of stuff uh they do
like uh
yeah i'm looking now adult improver so
basically
like how do regular noobs get better at
chess yeah uh one of the things they one
of the person that said i think he's the
grandmaster but he said uh
to maximize the amount of time you spend
every day of like
basically as you were saying like
suffering so like
you it's not about the like you should
be thinking you should be doing
calculating so it's the opposite of what
magnus said like
you should be doing a lot of time it
doesn't matter what the puzzle is or
whatever the hell you're doing but you
should be like doing that difficult
calculation that's how you get better
yeah it really depends what you're
training because i used to think the
same but it depends what you're weak
you're at because if you're doing the
really difficult puzzles you're training
for like visualization and calculating
more moves ahead than you typically
would which maybe you wouldn't get into
that as often in a regular game because
typically you run into like three to
four tactics which are actually the
easier and more fun ones to solve so it
really depends and on top of that as a
hobbyist your motivation is very
different than when you're playing from
a young age and have pretty high
competitive ambition
and
a lot of people who are new to chess
you could basically work on anything and
still improve
so if you're focusing on something you
like you're probably going to stick to
it more and be more consistent which i
think is more helpful long term what was
the most embarrassing loss
of your career
i had so many flashbacks but i'm so glad
it's a question for andrea i like that
you specified you know it's funny
because
i mean because you said you're so
competitive and like yeah no i could
tell just even from the way you said it
that
like you hate losing yeah i mean that
was the reason i hated chess in high
school because it'd always be like but
okay there's many traumatizing losses
whereas you're like you're top three
you're running for first and then you
throw a game you shouldn't but and this
shouldn't hurt my ego as much as it does
um but it's always kids
or when i was a high school girl it's
the younger boys who are really cocky
and when they win they start rubbing it
in your face and they're yawning and
looking around when like
90 of the game you were destroying them
and you had this one tiny mistake and
now their ego is huge um but i'll never
forget i was playing like for a chess
scholarship um and i was it was
tiebreaker for first and i think i lost
to a 12 year old girl who couldn't even
use the scholarship but she beat me in
one first place and she got some other
prize um so yeah i was losing to that
little girl who's literally like 2 300
now so
makes sense all right you keep telling
yourself that what do you think because
do you think caspar was feeling that
when he was playing 13 year old magnus
like yeah why as much as it's a beauty
of the sport that any age can be
brilliant any demographic anything
um i feel like when you're adults and
you're paired against the kid it's just
hard not to let it get to key and it
depends maybe if they're a really sweet
kid but most times i play kids they're
just really arrogant and but i don't
think they do it intentionally because
they're kids i mean there is a certain
etiquette thing where like like you said
yawning and in general like it's not
kids there's no etiquette yeah yeah
yeah the kids traumatized me too i was
playing in vegas and
it was not even my opponent it was the
board next to me and the kid was at
least 10 years old made 12 max and he
was playing against an adult and he
takes out his hand and he starts doing a
fake phone to which the kid studying
sitting across diagonally picks up their
banana and starts talking like it's a
phone and they're just mouthing words
why their two adult opponents are
thinking intensely at the game and then
i see the adult look up look at the kid
just making banana phones and then
destroying his eyes as he sighs
yeah and they're not even doing for
trash talking no no they're just
bored kids yes exactly what was the
because you you played a bunch of uh
people for for your channel uh what was
the most like memorable what's the most
fun most intense
there's a bunch of fun ones you've
played kids before some trash talking
kids
that sounds great
they trash talk kids yeah nothing like a
loser 12 year old who then starts doing
a fortnight dance yeah
so that that actually happened that did
happen he he is uh you know a very young
master i think he became master when he
was like nine years old or something and
he's very good at chess and doing a lot
of training but he's also incredibly
good at trash talking and he beat me one
game and he stood up and he started
doing the fortnite dance
so you know you gotta just swallow your
pride in those moments what is that
culture of like street chess players it
seems it seems pretty interesting like
um
i don't know that seems to be
celebrating the beauty of the game it's
the trash talking but also having fun
with it but also taking it seriously
and you've done a few of those did you
go to new york yeah in union square park
washington square what was that like
it's such a unique place i haven't seen
it anywhere else in the us where people
are just
professional chess hustlers even if
they're not necessarily you know a top
player but they play chess every single
day and so many of them learned chess by
themselves and never had a professional
coach so they are quite good at it
they're also very tight-knit they all
know each other and it's a very social
thing where you're not just playing
chess it's the experience of getting to
know this person who's a
very much a personality and they talk to
you they could either give you tips or
they can be really chatty and talk to
you during so it's a chess experience
rather than just playing a game do you
tell them like what your rating is or do
you just let people just like
both ways do you discover how good the
actual the person actually initially i
loved going and not telling people my
rating and just surprising them and and
winning games but now we've gone so many
times that they just know us so we can't
get away with it anymore one time
actually i don't know if i should share
this but one time
we dressed up as grandmothers and we had
prosthetics on our face yeah and i think
they still recognized us
yeah it's probably the
there's other components like probably
the trash talk and all that it was
actually no it was funny we were talking
like grandmothers but it was the way i
held
it was the way grandmother didn't talk
like you don't want it
oh
okay what were your names what were the
code names oh my god i think it was edna
edna and i had a really uh i can't
remember the other one
but it was embarrassing because we were
walking so slowly and andrea dropped her
cane or something at one point then
people in the park they were able to
help her we felt so happy
but but yeah it was funny because they
didn't know it was us until he saw the
way i reached for my pond and he said
the way you held your pawn i knew it was
you it was like such a sneesh thing that
was what blew the grandma cover
uh yeah do you have a style of how you
play physically
is that i didn't think we did until
grandma went to play chess but yeah i've
never thought about that yeah i think
our style is just trash talking now
it's style is very if you're talking
about style on and youtube and twitch we
definitely have a distinctive style
what's that what's your distinction i'm
just talking [ __ ]
but not going too far no no definitely
that's that's definitely going to if
it's us two against each other oh we we
trash talk each other so hard so and i
love looking at andrea
as she's annoyed and the satisfaction i
get when that happens
how many times do you play against each
other on online publicly i think i've
seen a couple of games played a lot of
times we try not to do it too often
because it's repetitive but every now
and then when we haven't done it for a
while we'll go at it again what do you
mean repetitive is like is that implied
trash talk right there no it just we we
place similar openings so you just start
seeing the same position you offer each
other every time
andrea is really good at opening so i
just start playing bad openings to get
her out of her preparation because i
don't like opening theory very much i
just like playing the game and getting
into middle
games and end games but yeah typically
the only time we're playing each other
is when we're setting up in the park and
we don't have opponents yet and we need
content so we just play each other until
people show up but we always put stakes
on the line which makes it more very
interesting because otherwise it
wouldn't be fun to play each other if
there's no stakes where's where is the
most fun place you've you've played is
in new york i think so and it was
actually when we set up in times square
one night we just brought a table with
us and chess and it's not even where
people usually play chess but it was
so lively there were all of the lights
out and so many people just kept
stopping by to play chess and it was
really one of my favorite streams just
the opposite of like the classical chess
world it's super loud there's music
there's cars there's street dancers even
some naked people walking around who we
had to be careful not to get banned yeah
but i honestly really like the chaotic
environments for chess games because i
think it's a good way to break more into
the mainstream culture and make it
entertaining and appealing to anyone who
doesn't know anything about chess
and also in an authentic way because
it's what we really like about chess
when you're just enjoying the game but
also the atmosphere and the people who
you're playing with and that's one of
the things that i think you see less
when you're just thinking of chess as a
competitive thing
you've uh you mentioned a few other
games like the bobby fischer games the
candidates match the game of the century
which i feel like is a is a weird game
to call the game of the century when
there's still like a few decades left in
the century but yeah i mean it wasn't an
official thing it was just the chess
journalist on a chess article but it
stuck if you look yeah no it didn't
wikipedia this is all i do research-wise
because there's so that particular one
was
a 13 year old fisher
and he did a queen sacrifice
i wonder is it there's that movie
searching for bobby fisher was that
related because didn't have a young
somebody who's supposed to be kind of
like bobby fischer played by josh
wadeskin yeah i think he ended up being
an international master it wasn't based
on bobby fischer was based on another
player but i liked how they told it
through the lens of being inspired by
bobby fischer do you remember that game
of like why do you think it was dubbed
the game of the century it was just
journalists being like i i think part of
it was the atmosphere where you have the
us junior champion who's this 13 year
old nobody and it's the first time he's
playing in a very competitive landscape
against some of the top american players
and he goes up against an international
master so somebody who's a lot stronger
than he is who's played in you know
olympiads for the american team he's
having a bad tournament but then he has
this one game where he just shows off
his uh tactical prowess and plays
incredibly well and i don't know if this
is true but in the paper clippings of it
they'd say things like grandmasters were
by the board and they would say things
like oh bobby is lost in this position
what is he doing but there's this 13
year old kid who's just playing
incredibly well and then that also
happened before
bobby's started really rapidly improving
at chess not that people knew that but
he kind of seemed like a rising star so
i think the game was beautiful but i
also think the idea of a 13 year old kid
coming out from nowhere and beating a
top american player was very fascinating
and there was aggressive chess and it
was in the interesting ideas
um yeah taking big risks it's cool to
see a 13 year old do that yeah
uh what about the you you mentioned that
his match against uh
mark
taimana from their 71 candidates match
was interesting in some way why is it
interesting to you
i'm move 45 i'm looking at some notes
this is with the bishop e3 i think i
know which one you're talking about um
it's
i wouldn't say
a lot of these games on these lists i
think are really great combinations that
that
when tactics come into play which is
what we're talking about but they're
very good at exemplifying lessons
this is why you study famous games so
you can apply these lessons to your own
games and i think the main takeaway for
this one was they were punishing their
opponent from steering away from opening
principles which is something that we
learned a little earlier
where he delayed the development of his
king and put his queen out a little bit
too exposed so bobby fischer immediately
punished that and then there was just
like a beautiful combination where it
was like a
12 in a row perfect moves which was a
tactic just winning the game but it only
came from punishing those mistakes the
mistake being bringing the queen out
bringing the queen out and yeah not
castling your king right away
and these were just like opening
principles that now they're written in
books but but for books you would study
these principles by studying games
and also
i'm looking at some notes his dominance
during the candidates tournament was
unprecedented
he swept two top grand masters i mean
that guy's meteor cries is incredible
sad that i think at whatever in his 20s
he then quit chess
one has to wonder what
where he could have gone
yeah it is sad that
we lost such a brilliant mind so early
on and it's also sad i think kind of
what ended up happening in his life and
the slowly going crazier is there some
aspect of chess that
opens the door to crazy
like like how challenging it is on you
the stress the anxiety of it
the isolation and being isolation yeah
this is a very lonely sport it is even
to you guys since you both play it it's
still lonely the experience of it it was
when i was competing a lot i think the
crazy part of it for me was how obsessed
you can get about a board game where
you're optimizing your entire life to
beat another person at you know pushing
wooden pieces across the board and it
doesn't necessarily translate to other
things and the fact that so many people
spend so much of their life on it but
you can also spend so much of your life
because it's so deep and so interesting
and i mean i've definitely experienced
moments where
i didn't want to do anything but chess
and i had that before
i went to college where i just wanted to
take a gap year and focus on chess
because
i still i went to high school we moved a
lot there was always other things going
on so i felt like i could never really
focus on chess
and the one time i could by taking a gap
year i ended up not doing because my
parents really wanted me to go to
university right away but i think maybe
if i had taken that gap year i don't
know if i would have gone back to school
so maybe it wasn't a bad thing i also
say that's pretty universal i think if
you want to be that the best at anything
you do or any sport you have to be that
level of obsessed so i don't know if
that's only chess
well some things some obsessions are
more transferable to a balanced social
life
that is like healthy development yeah
chess is a lot less social than most
other sports yeah there's something
deeply isolating about this game i mean
the the great chess players i've met i
mean they
it's like it's really competitive too
and there's
something that
you're almost non-stop
paranoid about
blundering
at every level and that develops a
person who's really anxious about losing
versus someone who like deeply enjoys
perfection or winning and so on it's
just this constant paranoia about losing
maybe i'm like misinterpreting it but um
that gets that that creates a huge
amount of stress
over like thousands of games
especially in a young person
and
that blundering is such a painful
experience because
you could be playing a game that you've
played for five six hours and you have
one lapse in focus and you blunder and
you throw the entire game away and
sometimes not just the entire game but
the entire tournament now you can't
place or do anything anymore so you just
feel those mistakes so strongly yeah
there's no one to blame but yourself
are you as hard on yourself have you
have you been
about losing like before you became
super famous for streaming where you
could be like well [ __ ] this at least i
can
i can so i was really hard on myself and
i went to play a tournament in canada to
try to qualify for the olympiad team
and
i was like well i'm an adult now i'm not
gonna feel emotional if i lose and then
i got there on the first day i think i
was ranked like fourth in canada for for
females
um and how long ago was this this was
like uh earlier in the year actually
and i go and i lose to somebody lower
rated on the first day and i think it
was because i had blundered and i went
back to my room and i was like i am not
an adult i'm not eating i'm not leaving
this room i feel terrible and i know i
shouldn't but it just cuts so deep um
and then i actually ended up qualifying
for the olympiad team but i didn't want
to play because i didn't have enough
time to train and the losses are so
painful that i was like it's not worth
it
yeah it's in high school and growing up
i was i just remember weekends and i i
think being competitive in any sport
again probably people relate to this
versus like spending weekends crying and
even like alex said like punishing
yourself because you're disappointed in
yourself because you fight so hard and
you prepare and you study and you're
like oh
i
yeah but that's once again on the right
side though when
you're studying so hard and after like a
four hour game and you actually are on
the opposite end and you win you feel
like such a huge rush of dopamine and
serotonin and you're like on a high from
the wind so there's also plus sides or
you can turn this around but yeah like
alex said like losing after preparing
for something and fighting on hours and
hours is the worst feeling in the world
did you ever get anything like that with
martial arts
yeah so you know wrestling i wrestled
all through high school in middle school
definitely so it's an individual sport i
did a lot of individual sport tennis
those kinds of things
but i think even with wrestling and
tennis you're still on a team right you
can still like
there's still a camaraderie there i feel
like with chess especially go on your
own with the tournaments like it you
really are alone but i i mean i always
personally just had us like a very
self-critical mind in general i would
not that's one of the reasons i decided
not to play chess
because uh i think when i was really
young i met
somebody uh
who was able to play blindfold chess
yeah they were teaching me they were
laying in there on the couch trash
drinking and smoking
and they were sounds like a russian yeah
exactly um there are now a faculty
somewhere in the united states i forget
where but
he um
making jokes talking to others and he
would move the pieces
like he would yell across the room
and i remember
thinking that
if a person is able to do that
then that kind of world you can live in
inside your mind that becomes the chess
board to me that meant like the chess
board is not just out here it could be
in here and you could do these beauty
you can create these beautiful patterns
in your mind
i thought like
i
had such a strong pull towards that
or where i had to decide either i'm
gonna dedicate everything to this
or not
uh you can't do half-assed and then i
that's when i decided
um to walk away from it because i had so
much other beautiful things in my life i
loved mathematics i loved just
everything was beautiful to me i thought
chess
would pull me all in
and
there was nothing like it i think in my
whole life since then i think it's such
a dangerous addiction
it's such a beautiful addiction but it's
a dangerous one depending on what your
mind is like it reminds me of something
i thought of
before i stopped competing as much and
i'd look at people and think
imagine being
so intelligent that you could become a
grand master and yet only spending the
rest of your life being a grandmaster
because it's one of those things where
it does require a lot of mental power
but by doing chess you're not going to
be able to explore other subjects deeply
yeah and not in a way that is is bad
necessarily more in admiration and
wondering what else could have been
because i've just seen people get to
these levels of obsession where it's all
they want to do and they're grandmasters
but they're not even top players so
they're never going to make a living out
of it they'll make like maybe 30 40k
your max they can't even focus on their
competitive chess because they have to
supplement it by you know teaching and
doing things they don't like and it's
just because of how strong of an
obsession it can be because it truly is
very intellectually rewarding
and i think that's what people are
addicted to and the self-improvement but
you can get that from a lot of other
things as well
well i think for me what i was inspired
by that stuck with me is that
a human being could be
so good
at
one thing
right to me that person on the college
drinking so on i
i assumed he was the best chess player
in the world like that to be able to
play inside your head right
uh
it just felt like a feat that's
incredible and so i
fell in love with the idea that i hope
to be something like that in my life at
something it's it would be pretty cool
to be really good at one thing and like
life in some sense is a search for the
things
that you could be that good at i didn't
even think about like how much money
does it make or any of that
is can i fall in love with something
and make it a life pursuit where i can
be damn good at it and the being damn
good at it
is the source of enjoyment not
not like um
not to win because you want to win a
tournament or win because
uh
like you just want to be better somebody
else no it's for the beauty of the game
itself or the beauty of the activity
itself and then you realize that that's
one of the compelling things about chess
it is a game with rules and you can win
if you want to be really damn good in
some aspect of life like that
it's
it's harder
it's a harder and weirder pursuit don't
you feel like you kind of did that with
computer science or ai related things
like getting that level of
damn good
that's one of the cool things about
ai and
robotics or intellectual pursuits or
scientific pursuits is you can spend
until you're 80 doing it so i'm in the
early days of that one of the thing
reasons i came to texas
one of the reasons
i didn't want to pursue an academic
career at mit
is i want to build
a company
and so that i'm in the early days of
that ai company and so it's an open
world to see if i'm actually going to be
good at it but the thing that's
there
that i've been cognizant of my whole
life is that i have a passion for it
something within me
draws me to that thing and you have to
listen to that
to that voice so with chess
you're [ __ ] unless you like early on
are really training really hard
i think life is more forgiving
you can be you can be world-class at a
thing after
after making a lot of mistakes
and after spending the first
few decades of your life doing something
completely different in chess it's like
um it's like an olympic sport like
there's no
perfection is a requirement as a
necessity
what do you think is that pursuit for
you
like why did you decide to stream
what what drew you i like these
questions that were really getting deep
yeah this is like a therapy session i
mean what um isn't it terrifying to be
in front of a camera
well it's terrifying to be in front of
five cameras instead of corrections six
six okay more terrifying for me oh yeah
try to remember
if i actually turn them all i'm like i
mentioned to you off mike i'm still
suffering from a bit of ptsd after
uh screwing up a recording of magnus i i
uh he had to console me because
that was the thing is i
felt okay you want to you want to build
robots
if you can't get a camera to even run
correctly
how are you going to do anything else in
life oh no don't let it spiral like that
it was it was spiraling hard yeah and i
was just laying there and just just
feeling sorry for myself but i think
that feeling by the way
and a small tangent is really useful
like yeah i feel like a lot of growing
happens when you feel shitty as long
as long as you can get out of it like
don't let it spiral like indefinitely
but just feeling really really shitty
about everything in my life like i was
having an existential crisis like how i
how will i be able to do anything at all
like this you're a giant failure all
those kinds of negative voices
um but i think i made some good
decisions in the in the week after that
do you think you couldn't have made
those decisions if you were less hard on
yourself
me personally
no i'm too lazy
okay so you really need to be angry at
yourself enough to go and do whatever
yeah it's not even angry it's just upset
of being self-critical like
also for me personally because i don't
have
proclivities for depression
i
have a lot more uh room to feel
extremely shitty about myself
uh so
if you if you're somebody that can get
stuck in that place like clinically
depressed you have to be really really
careful you have to notice the triggers
you don't want to get into that place
but for me
just looking empirically feeling shitty
has always been
productive
like it makes me long-term happier
ultimately it makes me more grateful to
be alive it helps me grow all those
kinds of things so i kind of
uh
embrace it otherwise i feel like i will
never do anything i have to feel shitty
but that's not a thing
i prescribed to others there's a there's
a famous professor at mit his name is
marvin minsky
and uh when he was giving advice about
like to the students
he said the secret to my success was
that i always hated everything
uh i did in in the past
so always sort of being self-critical
about everything you've accomplished
never really take a moment of gratitude
and i think for a lot of people that
hear that that's not good you should be
you should like take a pause and be
grateful but it really worked for him so
you know it's a choice you have to make
it reminds me of the quote be happy but
never satisfied
where
you can have a positive spin and still
want to improve yourself
but yeah um
like uh when did you decide to take a
step in the spotlight that terrifying
spotlight of the internet
it was actually my senior year of
college and i was really busy with work
and school
and chess was kind of like this lost
love and the interesting thing is that
the longer i don't play chess the more i
kind of miss playing it casually and
enjoy it more because then i start
looking at it with fresh eyes
but i didn't have time to play
tournaments so
i started streaming online because it
was more social than just playing
strangers on the internet without
knowing anything about who they are
and
i started slowly growing a community and
got in touch with chess.com pretty
quickly too so then it was this hobby
that i would do once a week every
thursday at 8pm and it was one of the
things that brought me a lot of joy and
actually i
speaking of depression did struggle for
with you know at least 10 years of my
life and it was one of those things
where
chess and streaming was such a
distraction and it brought me such great
joy
that i just kept doing it because i
really really liked it um and then
i was working on something that didn't
pan out and decided to go and take a
risk and just stream full-time which
you know seemed a little bit weird at
the moment but was that terrifying that
leap
it was terrifying but i had taken so
many terrifying leaps in the past and
they didn't and you know the last two
hadn't worked out but i was like well
i'll get it eventually
so somehow having failed before and
going through failure and knowing that
it'll be okay
made me more likely to just try
something that was a very very weird job
goodbye camera i thought it died yeah
the the camera that we don't need it oh
but one of the things luckily we have
another five yeah i know
like this is where this triggers the
spiral alexis
it's still it's still somehow awake um
is there advice you can give about
the dark places you've gone in your mind
the depression you suffered from how to
get out from your own from your own
story
whenever i go to those really dark
places the scariest thing is that it
feels like i will never get rid of this
feeling and it is very overwhelming
and
i just have to kind of
look back over
time spans and remember that every
single time i have got through it and
remind myself that it is just temporary
and that has been the most helpful thing
for me because i just try to combat the
scariest thing about it
and then believe have faith that it's
gonna
like this will go away and take action
obviously to make sure it goes away and
i've also tried to spin it as depression
is one of the hardest things i've had to
deal with but also one of the biggest
motivators because
if i just am left with my own brain i
get very depressed then i really like
working or focusing on things so it
actually pushed me to you know try to
focus on school try to focus on chess
focus on whatever i'm doing and also if
i'm feeling really bad then there's
probably something a little bit off and
i use it as a signal and try to think of
it as okay this is just a sign that
there's things that could be improved
for long term what about you andrea have
you gone to dark places in your mind
i'd say i
my family like like i see alex going
through this my mom also has very
serious depression luckily i got the
genes where i don't go through that
serious
level of depression that they do i say
mine is much more temporarily so it's
more similar to what what i was feeling
when i was exactly feeling shitty here
he is yes exactly where like but i know
that it's not something that's clinical
and that's
just a
genetic thing or a mental thing where as
i know it's more serious for like my
family members um and i did relate a lot
with you where you're saying where that
really pushes you and i felt that a lot
through content where you just kind of
feel hopeless
and kind of like an existential crisis
where i don't like the content i'm doing
and that's what pushes me to like okay
you have no choice but to try something
that now you're going to be passionate
about because otherwise you're going to
be stuck in this never-ending cycle um
so it does it's short-term and then um
it helps me come up with the things that
i enjoy the most content-wise and it
also long-term taught me just how to
have a more balanced life like doing
small things that make me happier on a
daily basis to like working out to
eating healthier which i notice when i
don't do for weeks i just get a lot more
depressed
what has playing chess
taught you about life
has
hasn't made you better at life in any
kind of way or has it made you worse you
know a lot of people kind of romanticize
the idea that chess is kind of like life
or life is kind of like chess
and becoming better at making decisions
on the chess board is going to make you
better at making decisions in life is
there some truth to that
i always shy away from these comparisons
with
chess and life
um
because yeah it has both positives and
negatives so one thing it really helps
develop from an early age is having an
analytical mind but then you could also
get like paralysis of analysis where
you've just thought of everything to
death and you're moving too slowly when
you just have to keep going forward
because there's not a great path ahead
so it's more like exercising your brain
and
staying sharp and then also applying
that to other things whereas if instead
of playing chess or watching tv or
something like that you'd probably end
up being less sharp
yeah i used to
in high school i'd always preach like ah
chess transfers for life skills at
college i would teach
i taught chess for juvenile department
for special education school i had site
studies in prisons where like oh playing
chess helped them with x and for your
kids it helps with teamwork and thinking
over life choices and now that i'm older
i don't believe in any of that bs but
um i do think that the process of
working really hard at something which
takes really long to see results and you
have to be really dedicated and like i
remember in high school and in middle
school well all my friends they were
having fun on the weekends and i'd have
to be there studying towers of chess a
day and knowing one day will pay off but
for like two three years nothing paid
off kind of learning that type of
patience with anything it's like you
know like getting a real job i can't say
i ever really worked a real job in my
life since i went straight into
streaming and i got to work for myself
but i'd say it's
what people go to college for like they
learn how to live in the real world and
i'd say that that's what chess taught me
as a kid
when you're streaming when you're when
you're doing the the creative work do
you feel lonely so a bunch of creators
talk about sort of the
it's it's counterintuitive because
you're famous now
but it's you know
sort of not quite but
we're very lucky to have each other so
is that the source of the the comfort
and the
like is there some sense where it's
isolating
to have these personalities they have to
do to always be having fun being wild
and so on
or is it actually the opposite like is
it a source of comfort to know that
there's so many cool people out there
that are giving you their love and
it started as a source of comfort
because it started with a very small
community who would be something it
would be around 200 to 300 viewers and
you know only like 30 to 40 of them
would actually chat actively so you felt
like it was a community not an audience
so you like knew them personally almost
yeah exactly and it was people who were
interested in chess um and i would
really enjoy that and then as you know
we started growing bigger the audience
kind of changed where
they're not there for you personally
they're there while you're entertaining
um and it
changed for me and i ended up being a
lot more self-conscious of things online
and started even thinking of myself more
like a product than a human being when
i'm online because i had to brand yes
exactly otherwise you just start taking
everything personally that people
comment about you and it's based off of
very small
i see so it was almost a kind of a
defense mechanism exactly
and it took time to get enough
because even if you have tough skin
eventually it gets to you when you're
online every single day listening to you
know thousands of people's feedback on
you
i think the loneliest part of being
creator is going through burnout which
everyone is just it's bound to happen um
which is why i think we're very lucky
that we have each other because right
it's a numbers game and you're viral and
trendy at one point and then you have to
fall and then there's months where
you're just grinding and i just every
day i'm like andrea we're relevant
that's that's really like the worst part
of being creative and figuring out how
to get over that hump but makes me very
grateful that i have my sister because i
know that i'm not the only person going
through it um and
yeah i know that most of my creator
friends feel very lonely in that process
because they don't have someone who's
their family and their business partner
and they're working by each other side
by side you kind of tie in your
self-worth to your job and your content
and maybe even more extremely than other
jobs because you also are
the entire company in the entire product
so when things are going well or when
things are not you just need to be
careful to not reflect like oh i am
doing bad i am better other than the
trends have now changed there's outside
things we're going to keep going and
this is just the normal waves which is
how we think about it now and also just
about are we enjoying it this is this
what we want to make but
we were stuck in the the camp for a
while when we
10xed our viewership um after the
pandemic because people were home and
playing chess and then of course that
dropped by like 70 and then you see that
and you're trying your best um and you
just kind of have to deal with it and be
like okay i'm just gonna keep
persevering and maybe it'll get better
that's so fascinating i mean this is a
struggle
of sorts in the 21st century
of like
how to be an artist how to be a creator
how to be an interesting mind
in response to this algorithm i'm
telling you turning off views and likes
is really good i don't look at twitch
views for that reason and i get obsessed
with the numbers too and i know andrea
does but for me
what i try now is to be more focused in
the moment but andreas somehow can do it
even with the views
so you just you get you have fun with it
it's like ooh number one i'm too much of
like a given to the temporary
satisfaction like i like seeing i'd like
knowing that if something happens right
now viewership's going to boost by a
couple hundred and seeing that i'm right
of course but what about when the
viewers started exactly well and i
always like you just have this intuition
now and but i think also the reason that
it doesn't affect me so much is when we
first started our content journey we
were only twitch streamers and we our
livelihood were based on twitch viewers
but now like i've learned how to recycle
that content into like youtube and
shorts and other things where i know
like okay if this stream does badly
there's so many more things you can do
that also just have a much larger output
so it doesn't get to me as much as it
did
do you ever feel that with your podcast
or do you feel like it's been authentic
since the start no so
there's there's a million things to say
there so one
is there's a reason
i stopped taking a salary at mit
and moved to texas is i wanted my bank
account to go to zero because i do my
best with my back against the wall so
one of the comforts i have is i don't
care if this podcast is popular or not
i wanted to not be popular so i don't
want it to make money failing lex yeah i
want i want to i mean i just do best
when i'm um
more desperate that's like one thing to
say seems like a reoccurring theme with
how you build up your greatest work
which is honestly very respectable
yeah so uh
i thank you that's just like uh i would
recommend it
right thank you for finding it don't try
it the silver lining for an unhealthy um
mental state um
but the other thing is i was very
conscious just like with chess and those
kinds of things
that
i love numbers and i i would be if i
paid attention
if i tried to be
somebody
at their best like a mr beast who
uh really pays attention to numbers i
would just not
i'd be become destroyed by it
the highs and lows of it and i just
don't think i'll be creating the best
work
uh possible
uh but
one of the i mean they're
one of the big benefits of a podcast
it's listeners
and there's an intimacy with the voice
and i think
that is much more stable
and a deeper and more meaningful
connection than youtube youtube is a
fickle
mistress it's like it's a weird drug
that like
uh it really wants you very addicting
feedback loops when you have a video
that's number one out of ten yeah oh my
god the the adrenaline you get and then
the the thing i really don't like also
is the world
uh
like will introduce you
as a person that has a video on youtube
with some x number of views like the
world wants you to be addicted to these
numbers
because they associate it with having
done a good job yeah because that's what
people think views are even if it's not
right and because and primarily because
they don't have any other signal
of what's a good job i think the much
better signal is people that are close
to you your family your colleagues that
say wow that was cool i listened to that
that was really i didn't know this this
was really powerful this is really
moving and so on
but definitely i'm not terrified of
numbers because i i feel like just like
i said
i'd rather be um
i would rather be a stanley kubrick
right you you'd rather create
great
art like
um not to be pretentious but the best
possible thing you can create whatever
the beauty that's the capacity for
creating beauty that's in you i would
like to maximize that and i feel like
for some people like mr beast i think
those are perfectly aligned
because he just loves the most epic
thing possible but not for everybody i
think there's a lot of people for whom
that's not perfectly aligned
and so i'm definitely one of those and
i'm still really confused why anybody
listens to this anyway
um
but that's also something i guess you're
trying to find
trying to figure out i i get very afraid
of ever becoming someone who just makes
junk food content where you can't stop
while you're in the moment and it has
all of your attention but when you're
done it didn't really bring any value to
your life which is something that i
think the algorithm still does really
reward
and making sure that as we are learning
how to create better content it's still
something that is going to be meaningful
long term
well ultimately
you know you inspire a lot of young
people
uh this
yeah those are the best when i get
messages from people who are like i
played you a year ago and my rating was
1400 and now i'm 1900 i'd like to
challenge you again it's a 14 year old
writing a former email those things are
always very very fun to get and even
just outside of chess it's just
empowering to see and like for young
women too to see that kind of thing and
you guys are um being yourself
and making money from being yourself and
having fun and like growing as human
beings
which i think is really inspiring for
people to see
um so in that sense it's really
rewarding and then like the way i think
about it is um
there is some benefit of doing
entertaining type of stuff
so that
you get the
um
kind of like mr beast does with
philanthropy right the bigger mr beast
becomes the more effective he is at
actually doing positive impact on the
world so right those things are tied uh
tied together but of course with with
podcasts
you guys well maybe you have these kinds
of tense things but
what kind of ideas what kind of people
do platform
what kind of person
um
what kind of human being do you want to
be
because you're actually becoming a
person
and um
a set of ideas in front of the public
eye and you have to ask yourself that
question really hard like really
seriously because uh if you're doing
stuff in private
you have the complete luxuries to try
[ __ ] out right i think you have less of
a luxury to try [ __ ] out because the
internet can be vicious and punishing
you for trying [ __ ] out and do you think
that's sometimes a bad thing where you
have less freedom to make mistakes
yeah you have two choices so one you put
up a wall and say i don't give a [ __ ]
what people think
i don't like doing that because i like
being fragile to the world keeping my
sort of wearing my heart on my sleeve
uh or the other one yeah you have to be
you have to
you have to actually think through what
you're gonna say
you have to think of like
what do i believe you have to be more
serious about
um what you put out there
it's annoying but it's also actually you
should have always been doing that
you should be deliberate with your
actions and your words
um
but i don't know it's uh
but some of it it's such a balance
because
some of my favorite people are brilliant
people that allow themselves to act
ridiculous and be silly elon musk who's
become a good friend
is the silliest human of all i mean he's
incredibly
uh brilliant and productive and so on
but allows themselves to be silly
and that that's also inspiring to people
like you don't have to be perfect you
don't have to
you can be a weird a giant weird mess
and it's okay it's a it's a balance
i think when you start to delve into
political topics into topics that
really get tense for people then you
have to be a little bit more careful and
deliberate
um but it's also wise to stay stay the
hell away from those topics in general
uh like i mentioned to you offline
somebody i
have been debating whether i want to
talk to nas kuryakin on the chessboard
because
you know chess is just a game but
throughout
the history of the 20th century it was
played between the russians and the
americans and so on where
they were at war cold or hot war
and those are interesting
those those are interesting um
conversations to be had at the olympics
and so on it's not just a game it's some
sense it's like a mini war
and so i have to decide whether i want
to talk to to him or not and those kinds
of things you have to make those kinds
of decisions
for now you guys are not playing chess
with donald trump or obama or so on
we are not right now no
how long is a stream like a few hours
right now they're two to three hours
when i was first streaming i'd stream
for like six hours a day a day at least
usually yeah for like seven six to seven
days just like a talking one no i would
be playing chess the entire time while
talking and
when i started streaming uh
that's kind of how everybody blows up on
twitch you're just putting in crazy
hours and you're always there it's not
about making the best content it's about
letting people feel like they're hanging
out with you and just being on as much
as you can
but i ended up feeling very burnt out
because it's hard to be your best self
when you're in front of a camera for
that long because you
do
get scared of going into places where
you want to learn but you might not be
the best in because it's harder to learn
in public than do something that like
yeah we're better than 99 of our viewers
at chess so that's a lot less scary than
trying to
play a game that you're bad at or
discuss topics that you're interested in
yeah be
have the beginner's mind and be dumb at
something right yeah which is where the
fun is and you get to learn together but
people punish you for it on the internet
um what about you
andrea yeah i think like alex said at
the beginning when we were grinding a
lot you don't really even have time for
much of a private life because you're
streaming
every hour of your life and people want
it like
the appeal of streamers it's called like
being parasocial where you feel like
they're your friend and they like it
because they want you to share
everything about your life
um really the main challenge for me
at first when trying to prioritize
uh
quantity over quality which we're not
doing anymore was realizing that i can't
turn everything i'm interested in and
every passion into content
before i'm like well i must stream more
but i like music and i like playing
piano and i like reading into these
topics and i like fitness and then i try
to live stream all of it and that's just
at some point it's like just enjoy your
time off for those hobbies and
prioritize what you're good at because
that's just going to be better for the
channel overall so that was a learning
lesson for sure it's nice because there
are some intersections when i have tried
new things that i really enjoy and it
pays off but that's more uh less often
so it's more like you can be yourself
but only specific parts of yourself
online
and
the rest sometimes it's nice to just
keep private and
feel that you could just
give it your 100 freedom
see i i i feel like um
i try to be the exact same person
on podcasts as in private life i really
don't like
hiding anything but you're also a
generalist right where you have people
with all topics for us we built our
audience off of very specific things so
people sometimes feel like even at the
start when we started playing less chess
they're like i subbed for chess why are
you not playing chess
exactly people are tuning in for an
interesting conversation on a bunch of
topics so like the more you are yourself
the better it is but it is very hard
when you build your brand on like one
type of gaming content
build your
brand
but yeah the way you become a journalist
is you slowly expand
it's like uh like uh
expanded checkers
i guess that's that's a downward uh
maybe poker poker yeah exactly poker but
also just the ideas the space of ideas
and one of the cool things about chess
is when you're talking over the
chessboard
you're it's a kind of podcast you know
that is actually an idea we've had with
playing chess while also doing a podcast
and talking with people it's kind of
like an ice breaker where you're also
focusing on the game at the same time
but you know we are slowly evolving and
we're doing more things like one thing
we wanted to do is spend less time in
front of the computer so now we're doing
a chess travel show where we go to
different countries and look at the
chess culture so it actually feels like
we're doing things that we would want to
do and explore anyway and maybe it's not
as much in the idea space which we both
enjoy and do a lot in our own free time
but in the
sharing and cool experiences with our
audience that we actually want to do
what do you look forward to going we're
going to romania um
on september 9th and i think this is the
most exciting for me because we're going
back to you know the country where our
entire family is from
where our grandmother taught our dad who
taught us how to play chess it has a
very strong chess culture so it'll be
very unique to go back and see
um how everything is when we haven't
been back for a very long time and for
romanians like it's very rare when
there's like a famous romanian who
accomplishes something which is why like
right now andrew tate's the most famous
romanian but he's banned for a bad
reason exactly and there's like
something very special about romanian
pride and when we meet fellow romanians
in the us like it's just an amazing
connection and like i hear the way my
dad talk about like for example
nadia who was a famous romanian gymnast
and he's like yeah like romania we
sucked at everything but when she won
the olympics for gymnasts every kid on
the street was doing gymnastics because
it's very rare that they make it to that
level of success i'm not saying that
we're super successful super famous but
it is really cool to meet other
romanians through chess because it's a
very special bond
you you you feel
like it's a community and like you
belong yeah you can't get that anywhere
else
let me ask your opinion since you
mentioned him andrew tate you're both
women successful women you're both
creators so andrew t is an example of
somebody
that has become exceptionally successful
at
galvanizing public attention
but he's also
from any perspective of misogynist so
let me ask a personal question
do you think i should talk to him on
this podcast
how would you feel as a fan
as somebody i'm talking to the great
alex and andrea bortes and the next
episode is with andrew tay
i think it's a double-edged sword and
most of these things are not as black
and white as they seem
you know because on one hand i don't
agree with his beliefs and i think he
said a lot of things that are very
hurtful and that influence
people's opinions um
at the same time talking to someone
through that and trying to get to the
root of it and how much of it he used
just as a social media tactic to maybe
change the opinion of people who have
been so influenced by him towards
something that is maybe more
understanding towards women or things
like that could
do some good but at the same time
platforming someone like that and giving
them more attention also signals to
other people who have a platform that
it's okay so it's kind of weighing the
pluses and the minuses and it's a very
tough decision because it's not clear
and uh the thing about the internet when
you make the wrong decision you're gonna
pay for it
right
that's the thing like personally
and it is it is funny like i think the
whole way rose to fame is just the
growth hack and i've seen other people
do it where like you just say kind of
i don't
honestly i don't really listen to his
content because i just find it so dumb
but i think he knows that by saying the
dumbest
most controversial things that's like a
quick rise to fame and i think surface
level like he can really hold it up but
that's why i would honestly enjoy tuning
into a conversation where you're really
breaking down to the core of those
beliefs and i think like the young kids
who look up to him and when you actually
hear someone challenging it could
actually be helpful for people but at
the same time
it's a lot of bad publicity people see
your podcast they say wow like they
don't if they don't know you and they
don't know why you're interviewing him
and they don't listen they'll see that
and that 100
think it's for the other reason
but i'm also afraid of a society where
you can't have discourse with people you
don't dis with people you disagree with
and even though i don't like andrew tate
i think the fact that he got banned from
all the platforms is kind of scary
because it sets a precedent and you
always have to ask yourself would this
be ethical if i was on the other side
and even things with a president like
trump even if let's say you're somebody
who was on the left if that would have
happened to a leftist president how
would you feel would you think that's
morally ethical so
that is something that i think is
important we try to find ways to have
conversations and
reach some mutual understanding and try
instead of just amplifying the worst
about every human being
well so one of the major reasons i'm
struggling with is because i really
talking to brilliant women i think
it's also a lot of women reached out to
me saying like
it is what it is but they're inspired
when the female guest is on yeah and to
me if i talk to somebody like andrew day
even if i have a really hard hitting
i think it could be a very good
conversation
that
lessens the likelihood that
a brilliant powerful female will go on
the show
they'll never they'll never watch it but
the thing we're doing the society is we
put labels on each other well
lex is the person that platforms
misogynist
i did a thing where
um
joe rogan got in in trouble over an
n-word uh controversy earlier in the
year
and joe's a good friend of mine and i
said that i stand with joe that he's not
a racist or something like that
and
within certain communities i'm now
somebody who's an apologist for racists
right or a racist myself uh that kind of
thing and we put labels without ever
listening to the content without ever
uh sort of
actually just even the very simple step
or seems to be difficult of like
taking on the best possible
interpretation of what a person said
and giving him the benefit of the doubt
and having empathy for another person so
you have to play in this field where
people assign labels to each other
and uh
it's difficult but ultimately i believe
i hope that good conversations
is a way
to like a greater understanding for
people to
um
grow together as a society and improve
and learn the lessons the mistakes of
the past but you also have to play this
game where people just like putting
labels on each other and canceling each
other over those or that guy
said one thing nice about donald trump
he must be a far-right
nazi
or or the opposite that this person
um
says something nice about the vaccine he
must be a far left
um whatever because
apologist
for whatever for fauci
um
or most of us i think are ultimately in
the middle it's a weird it's a weird
thing but i think uh and it's also
painful on a personal level like
people people have written to me
about things like single words
half sentences that i've said about
either putin or zelensky
where they have hate towards me because
of what i
said either both directions i have now
accumulated very passionate people
that
some call me a putin apologist some call
me as a landscape apologist and it hurts
to
given how much i have family there how
much i've seen of suffering there and to
carry that burden over time and not let
it destroy you is tough so like do you
want to take on another thing like that
when you have conversations right or can
i just talk to awesome people like you
too
where it's not we're not controversial
it's or you're interesting you're
fascinating you're inspiring you're like
fun you know
not
all those difficult things that come
with more difficult conversations right
but somebody has to be making those
difficult decisions and
challenging the notions that
we should cancel someone just for
slightly disagreeing with us and it's
very hard to take that on personally and
i think that's a huge part of it when
you know it's something you're doing for
the right reasons and you're getting a
lot of people coming and misinterpreting
it it's very painful
but i think you have to ask yourself
long term
if when you made that decision you
ultimately thought it would be better or
worse for your listeners to know that
conversation and then if you can sleep
with it at night take the risk yeah when
actually when i talk to people that uh
especially like astrophysicists and you
realize how tiny we are right how
incredible like how huge the universe is
like you don't it doesn't matter you can
do anything you could like
um you can walk around naked talk [ __ ]
to people do whatever the hell
and uh actually modern social media
people will just like forget it's like
it's ultimately liberating just try to
do
at least from my perspective the best
possible thing for the world you can
take big risks it doesn't matter and
that's the other thing with being
canceled nowadays because everyone's
attention is much more short-sighted you
can get cancelled and then it'll blow
over in three days and you actually see
things like this on twitch very often
where people just have
outbursts of outrage and they come into
your chat and they're all spamming and
saying mean things and then three days
after and of course they're not actually
ever serious things they're usually like
things clipped of any streamers and like
their worst moments but then people
forget about it pretty soon after
so you're able to accept that
like when somebody's being shitty to you
for a day uh yeah i mean i still get
sometimes emotional about it especially
when i'm like oh wow like these things
are being said are not true or like this
is clearly taken out of context but i've
just accepted that it's part of the job
and if i am trying my best and i am
trying things with as good intentions as
possible then i just try to learn every
time that happens and be like okay what
could i do better and what is just part
of the job
well let's start some controversy who's
the greatest chess player of all time
uh is it magnus carlsen is the guerrilla
caspar visit somebody else bobby fischer
do you have a favorite alex
so whenever i hear this question i
interpret it in a very specific way
where it's not who was the most talented
chess player or who had the most impact
on the chess world but who is the
greatest at playing chess where if you
were putting all of these players at
their peak who would be the best
and
you know we're kind of living
in a world where obviously humans are
becoming more like cyborgs and their
tools make them a lot more powerful yes
um and
the computer is the most powerful tool
for chess that we've ever witnessed and
the top players now someone like magnus
carlsen or gary kasparov if they were
going to go towards people like you know
even lasker or bobby fischer back in the
day
lasker he was world champion for 27
years he was the best in his field by
far but would he be able to stand up to
someone like magnus carlson who has had
these tools
i don't think so
so
most chess players have said gary
kasparov um and i think even magnus has
said that in the past but i like to
think of it as magnus in his peak and
gary at his peak and because magnus was
able to live more in a computer era i
feel like so far he's the greatest of
all time and some studies say things
like how there's raiding inflation but i
looked into some of them and they
basically calculated people's um play in
over the years and it seems that there
hasn't been inflation people are just
getting better and i think it's because
you have better tools at chess
and also the one one of the cases what's
your
i was gonna say i actually i disagree
with that
good make it interesting i think i would
judge the greatest like greatest player
of all time
in relative to the time that they lived
in and magnus although
he is technically the strongest chess
player in history that is because he had
computers to study chess with and of
course
if you compare him to like gary kasparov
he plays most like stockfish but gary
kasparov at his time he beat more
players of his skill level than magnus
did magnus loses more often he also of
course held the belt for 20 years more
so i'd say actually because gary lacked
the help of computers to study chess and
overall performed better against players
of his skill level i think he would be
number one
nice
yeah but i mean the case that people
make for magnus
on many
i mean what alex said but but also
magnus plays a lot
and he doesn't
he plays a lot blitz bullet and
like he puts
he gets drunk and like he's really
putting himself out there
and in all kinds of conditions and he's
able to dominate in a lot of them we get
to see many of the like losses of
blunders and all that kind of stuff
because he just puts himself out there
and i think uh caspar was much more like
i never saw him play drunk right
and it's very focused on the world
championship is very like
um very limited number of games and very
focused on winning and so
there's some aspect to the versatility
the aggressive play the fun the all of
that
that i think you have to give credit to
100
in terms of just the
the
the scope
the scale of the variety of genius
exhibited by magnus and he might not
even be done yet i don't know if you'll
ever hit 2 900 but we can't judge yet
because he's not at the peak of his
career potentially what do you think
about him not playing world championship
isn't that like isn't that wild the
entirety of the history of chess in the
20th century going like meh
let's walking away from this one
tournament that
seems to be at the center of chess
um what do you think about that decision
i mean you can't help but be
disappointed as a chess fan who wants to
see the best player in the world defend
his title
but i also understand it on a personal
level and not feeling as satisfied when
you're
going to the world championship and have
to having to defend against people who
are
less strong than you and also imagine
winning world championships and not
feeling a joy out of that
yeah so maybe by not doing that and
focusing instead on a goal like 2 900
he'll be more likely to accomplish it
because he's focusing on
what actually motivates him to play
chess but i do think that it will
hurt how we judge
the next world champion
i think it won't change him being the
best player in the world
and for someone to replace him even
let's say like nepo versus sting even if
one of them win and right on some stance
it does lower the merit because now who
has the world chess championship title
isn't actually the best player in the
world and that has happened before in
the past but still going to take him
the same effort to prove when they would
pass him like 10 20 years to become
stronger than magnus so i don't think it
changes the skill level that it takes to
become the best chess player in the
world i think for chess fans it's very
disappointing but i think in the overall
like grand scheme of like the public
view to people who don't really
so like you know what breaks the popular
culture
and you think of what names people know
who don't play chess like bobby fischer
did it most people know casper over
magnus it takes the same ability and
talent and that doesn't change i think
it does change though if you're playing
a player who's not as strong
but i i see your point as well and i
know we differ on this like i heard you
asked magnus but what is your take on it
well
listen his answer is kind of brilliant
which
he's not saying he's he's bored of the
world championship he's
bored of a process that doesn't
determine the best player
like and it's too anxiety-inducing to
him to have a small number of games he's
he's
he doesn't mind losing which is really
fascinating to a better player right
or somebody who's his level he's more
anxious about losing
to um
a weaker player the weaker player
because of the small sample size now if
like poker players had that anxiety they
would never play at all right that's the
world series of poker you
you get to lose against weaker players
all the time that's the throw of the
dice but
um that's an interesting perspective
that he would love to play 20 30 40
games
in the world championship but then he
would enjoy it much more
and also play shorter games because they
emphasize the um
like pure chess actually being able to
like
like much more variety in the middle
game just to see a bunch of chaos and
see how you're able to compute calculate
and intuition all that kind of stuff and
yeah that's beautiful
i wish the chess world would step up and
meet him in a place that makes sense
you know change the world championship
so feed it changing it somehow that a
loss for that or having
other really respected tournaments that
become like an annual thing that step up
to that
or more kind of
online youtube type of competitions
which i think they're trying to do more
and more
like the crypto cup and all those kinds
of things yeah and the grand tour the
graduate does play in which takes a lot
of the top players and they do it online
in shorter formats
but there's you know and so that's his
perspective my
perhaps narrow perspective as i
romanticize the olympic games and those
are every four years and the
and the world championships
because they're rare because the sample
size is so small that's where the magic
happens everything's on the line for
you know for people that spend their
whole life
20 years of dedication
everything you have every minute of the
day is spent for that moment you think
about like gymnastics at the olympic
games there's certain sports where a
single mistake and you're [ __ ]
and that stress that pressure
it can
it can um
it can break people or it can create
magic
like a person that's the underdog
has the best night of their life or the
person that's been dominating for years
all of a sudden slips up that drama from
a human perspective is beautiful so i
still like the world championships but
then again
looking at all the draws
looking at like
well
the magic isn't quite there
so to me when i see faster games of
chess that's much more
that's much more beautiful so but that i
don't understand the game of chess
deeply enough to know
like does it have to be so um
so many draws
like is there a way to create a more
dynamic chess and he talked about random
chess like with a random starting
position that's really interesting but
then of course that
that's like then you do have to play
hundreds of games and that kind of stuff
right uh so i but i think
it's great that the world number one
is um
struggling with these questions
because he's in the position he has the
leverage to actually change the game of
chess
as it's publicly seen as publicly played
so it's um it's interesting he's still
young enough to to dominate for quite a
long time if he wants
so i don't know i you know i do with
kasparov the the the fight between
nations i i hope these have the world
championship
and i hope there's a
i hope he's still part of it somehow
i hope he changes his mind
and comes back comes back some kind of
dramatic thing i don't know
but it is it is his heart is not in it
and then
um
and then that's not beautiful to see
right
uh
yeah it is beautiful
that the thing he wants is a great game
of chess against an opponent that's his
level or better
and that's that's great that he's coming
from that place but i hope he comes back
tomorrow because the the world
championship is uh
is a special thing in any sport
so you do wish that the person who wins
the world championship is the best
player in the world
no
i hope that the best people in the world
the two best people in the world are the
ones that sit down
but the person that wins is the person
that that's the magic of it nobody knows
who's going to win i think magnus is so
he he really wants the best person to
win like the the
that's why he wants the large sample
size but to me there's some magic to it
the the stress of it the the drama of it
that's all part of the game like it's
not just about the purity of the game
like the the calculation
the pure chess of it it's also like the
drama
like
the yeah the the pressure the drama all
of it
the [ __ ] talking if it gets to you the
mind games yeah this is the part that's
fun to watch but less fun to be playing
to be but that's why it's great who can
melt who can rise under that pressure
and who melts under that pressure
uh what there's a lot of people to look
up to you like they're inspired by you
because you've taken a kind of
non-linear path through life is there
any advice you have for people
like in high school today
that are trying to figure out what they
want to do do they want to go to
stanford do they want to pursue a career
um in i don't know uh in industry or
or go kind of the path you guys have
taken which is have the ability to do
all of that and still choose to
make the thing that you're passionate
about your your life
i always like the calculated risks
approach where
when you're younger it's okay to take
more risks because you have a lot more
time
but there has to be a reason why you're
doing that particular risk is it
something that you've spent a lot of
time already really passionate and
working on or is it just something
that's trendy and you want to do it
because you don't have a better option
and that's actually similar to what
andrea did when she decided to go into
streaming instead of school
yeah it was the reason i got into
streaming because i was initially going
to go to college but the pandemics it
was right the beginning of the pandemic
and all my classes were online and i
never thought ever since i was 12 like
my dream was school and i saw myself
nowhere else than going to university
um and i just i thought of it and kind
of weighed out the wrist i'm like well
if i take a gap year and i try streaming
with my sister
what do i have to lose i gain some
experience working with someone who has
a lot more experience than i do um and
then i can go back to school after
and if i go to school right now i do
online classes for a year and that's
something that i could do at any time so
that's why it made a lot of sense for me
to go into this
but of course this is also a very unique
opportunity so i don't know how
applicable but i do think overall the
calculated risk is a really good it's a
life
is like chess
exactly maybe sometime exactly uh you're
also have you considered a career in
professional fighting i saw you did a
self-defense class these little jiu
jitsu did you see the 10 year old kid
who throwing her through her yes and
apparently i could have broken a leg but
it's actually funny like chest boxing is
a thing and i have been doing a lot of
boxing like
i physical activity is like honestly one
of my favorite things to do and i have
been testing it out on content and we
have a creative friend who's hosting a
chess boxing tournament but there's no
woman who's could match me unfortunately
because all the opponents are male yeah
and i can't fight a guy um how does
chess boxing work so you do a round of
chess and round of boxing and we
actually did a training camp for it
before and of course like after you go
into the ring is this real this
seriously actually yeah we went to the
london chess boxing club and like after
you've seen like videos i thought it was
something you did in russia or something
no it's a real sport yeah real sport
yeah no it's very cool but after you get
really tired you're more likely to make
a mistake
or something yeah there's probably good
strategies like what do you want to
because some of it is a cardio thing do
you want to work on your chest
they do both it's very fun
but yeah from a content perspective i'm
sure there's a lot of people that like
and would love very entertaining we'd
love to see
i don't want to see andrea getting hit
that would be i would love to oh she
doesn't get hit but i wouldn't get it
our roommate fought in a fight and she
did end up winning but seeing her get
hit i thought i was going to throw i
just think it was so cool she had no
experience in boxing whatsoever and then
coming from someone in the content world
where you start like waking up six days
a week at six a.m and he's training
every day like you know like a real
professional athlete i think like it's
such a unique experience and also like a
really test of how much you can really
commit to this and progress and i think
that's really rewarding and did you ever
end up doing the marathon with david
goggins that you were training i know i
got injured but we're gonna do it soon
that's on my uh uh bucket list just to
see what your limits are you're ready
what did you do leading up to this
it's meant it's mental anyway oh yeah
but i do run a lot to make sure like
there's no um
like
you know you have to be have a base
level of fitness to make sure your body
doesn't completely freak out but other
than that
you know 50 plus miles is just about
like
uh taking it one step at a time and just
being able to deal with the suffering
and all the voices the little voices
that tell you all the excuses like
why are you doing this
this blisters bleeding uh whatever
whatever the
the thing that makes you want to stop
just just shuts off sometimes it feels
like you like pain
no well
no no
but
the pain does seem to show the way to
progress
so what you're talking about am i in my
world something that's really hard and i
don't want to do that's usually the
right thing to do
and i
i'm not saying that's a
that's like a universal truth it's just
uh you know if there's a few doors to go
into the one that i'd want to go into
least that's the one that usually is the
right one
afterwards i will learn something from
it uh the david gaga's thing i don't
know that's listen i uh we're talking
offline the different the conversation
with liv she's a very numerous
calculated risk
everything is planned i i go with the
heart i just i just go whatever the hell
i think two years ago i woke up
it was
summer i i decided to tweet
i will do as many push-ups
i don't know why i did this
but i i'll do as many push-ups and
pull-ups as the sweet guest likes
something like that okay right and then
uh that you got like
30 000.
once you put it out on the internet
you're held accountable for myself i
mean
in some sense and then that's when i
already was connected to david
at that point but that's when he called
me
and then they have to do it and then i
did it was one of the hardest things
i've ever done
i got it i i did it for seven days and i
got injured so i did about a few
thousand so this is what got you to be
injured this challenge no it's different
i keep getting
keep getting injured doing some stuff
but this particular thing i started
doing the you don't realize that you
have to really ramp up
so i got uh like
overuse injury tendonitis on on the
shoulder all the way down to the elbow
so i took
like eight or nine days off and then
started again and then it took about
31 days to do
[Music]
i the number was like
26 27 000.
yeah because and i remember it took like
three four hours a day oh god yeah
sounds like torture and not you know in
the constantly asking myself what am i
doing in my life
this is why you're single what's the
voice of my head
this is what are you doing it's like
face down on the carpet
like
exhausted like what what because of a
tweet what is this
did you record it or you just i did i
did record it for myself okay now
imagine doing this every day and that's
what it's like to be a twitch streamer
just kidding right doing stupid things
that was really important to me actually
to not make it into content um
you know i recorded everything so maybe
one day i could publish it i recorded it
mostly because it's really hard to count
yeah when you get exhausted yeah like i
just so um you actually enter the zen
place where uh with push-ups
where it's just like it's almost like
like breathing you get into a rhythm and
you could do quite a lot
but i wanted to make sure like if i
actually get this done
i want there to be evidence that i got
it done for myself so i can count it i
had this idea that i would use machine
learning to like automatically process
the video to count it but then
like after like 10 days i didn't even
give a [ __ ] what anyone thought it was
about me versus me
i didn't even care lex versus lex yeah
and then uh
yeah and dave was extremely supportive
but that's when i realized like i really
want to go head to head with him
um yeah this those kinds of people are
beautiful they really challenge you to
your limits whatever that is it's like
the thing is physical exercise is such
an easy way to push yourself to your
limit there's in all other walks of life
it's it's trickier to configure like how
do you push yourself to your limits in
chess it's hard to figure out but like
do you think it's ever dangerous
yeah and that's what that's why it's
beautiful
the danger you like the pain i don't
like that your eyes lit up as i said
yeah
like if you don't know how you're gonna
get out of it
you're gonna have to figure out
something profound
about yourself
and i mean one of the reasons i went to
ukraine is i really wanted to
uh experience the hardship
and
the intensity of war that people are
experiencing so i can understand myself
better i can understand them better so
the words that are leaving my mouth are
grounded in a better understanding of
who they are and i mean the the the
running a lot with david gong is is a
much simpler
thing to do
um simpler way to understand something
about yourself about like the limits of
human nature i think most growth happens
with voluntary suffering or struggle
involuntary stuff that's that's where
the dark trauma is created but
i don't know well maybe maybe it is
maybe i'm just attracted to and what is
that your mind does when you're going
through this involuntary suffering
i think
it
there's like stages first all the
excuses start coming like why are you
doing this
and then
you start to wonder like what
what kind of person do you want to be
so all the dreams you had all the
promise you made to yourself and to
others all the ambitions you had that
are haven't come yet realized somehow
that all becomes
really intensely like visceral as as
this struggle is happening and then
when all of that
is allowed to pass from your mind you
have this clear appreciation of what you
really love in life which is just like
just living
just the moment the like the
step at a time like it's i think what
meditation does and it's most effective
it's just that pain is a as a catalyst
for the meditative process i think for
me
for me
i don't know
um magnus said there's no meaning to
life do you guys agree
or no why are we here
i do not know why we're here
but i do know that
having some kind of
meaning that i give my own life
makes it
a lot more motivating every day so i
just try to focus on finding meaning
within my own life even if i know it's
just
self-imposed
and then chess is a part of that
chess
is a part of it
maybe it was more so
when i was younger because it was easier
to just feel like i want to improve as a
person and
to use chess to kind of measure some
kind of self-improvement
and now it's
more different than that and i think i
need to once again find what that
you know
northern star is basically i need to
have a why for why i'm doing things and
then you i feel like i could do very
hard things
what uh role does love play in the human
condition
alex and andrea i'll let andrea start
this one since i took the last sure
and yeah just to add my answer for the
last one i i also
kind of think well life is meaningless
but i like the stoic idea where that's
something that you live to revolt
against
but for the second question
i have the revolt against the
fundamental meaninglessness of life
exactly
yeah
it was what does love play what role
does love play yeah in the human
condition
the way i see it i
love is a reason you want to share
experiences with other people
that's how i see it like the people you
really love you want to share the things
you're going through with them
um the good and the bad yeah exactly
that's my simple take on love
my take on it is that
part of what it is to be human is to be
somebody who
feels things emotionally and love
is one of the most intense feelings you
can have
um obviously there's the opposite of
that and there's things like hate but i
think the love you feel for people like
your parents and your friends and
romantic love in that moment is much
more
intense
than in other situations
um and i think it's also just very
unique to humans and that's
what i appreciate about it maybe that's
the meaning of life
maybe that's what the stoix is searching
for
andrea alex thank you so much for this
and thank you for an amazing
conversation thank you for creating keep
creating and thank you for putting
knowledge and love out there in the
world
thank you for having us
it was a pleasure and uh we're both big
fans of your podcast so this was really
exciting for us
thanks for listening to this
conversation with alexandra and andrea
botez to support this podcast please
check out our sponsors in the
description
and now let me leave you with some words
from bobby fisher
chess
is life
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time